So.
Leute, ich bin am Start.
Ist sonst noch jemand schon da?
Ja, da ist ja Banjo am Start.
Poggers.
Clani auch am Start.
Lizard, FTW.
Power Planter.
Jetzt kommen sie alle.
Oh, jetzt kommt schon der erste Sub.
Max Axel, Twitch Prime, Poggers.
Moment.
Mein Memeboard ist kaputt.
Jetzt geht's.
Ich habe es kaputt gemacht.
So.
Übrigens, Leute, ich weiß doch, dass ich Big Brain Chat habe.
Deswegen muss ich euch schon was fragen.
Und zwar habt ihr eine Idee.
Wobei, ich warte noch mal kurz, bis noch ein bisschen mehr Leute am Start sind.
Omega Kekfil.
Ich habe leider alle Emotes besetzt.
Sowohl bei FFZ, als auch bei WTTV.
Hauptsache abgekürzt alles.
Ist die Musiklautstärke eigentlich okay?
Ja, ich denke, es passt ganz gut.
Also, Leute, ich wollte euch noch was fragen.
Und zwar habt ihr eine Idee, wie man das Ganze hier anschließt?
Und zwar gehen wir mal auf Amazon.
Sorry.
Amazon.
Gehen wir auf Amazon.
Und dann suchen wir mal einen USB-SATA-Adapter.
Also, na, gucken wir mal.
Ich glaube, den habe ich hier.
Genau.
Habt ihr eine chlorreiche Idee, wie man...
Ich meine, das ist ein Adapter für USB für SSDs.
Ja, da ist kein extra Strom dabei oder sonst was.
Braucht man ja auch nicht.
So ist das gedacht.
Das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Ist im Prinzip das, was ich aus China bestellt habe, nur in Funktionierend.
Weil die habe ich euch ja...
Haben wir hier im Livestream ausprobiert.
Die haben wir ja auch ausprobiert.
Die USB-SATA-Adapter, die ich in China bestellt habe, die brechen ja ein bei der Übertragung.
Die sacken.
Sacken, richtig.
So.
Habt ihr eine chlorreiche Idee, wie ich es jetzt schaffen kann?
Also, ich habe eine Idee, aber die gefällt mir nicht so gut.
Dass ich von da, von dem Anschluss für die SSD, dass ich da einen SATA-Kabel reinstecken kann.
Weil, die Sache ist die, so wie das ist, kann ich das nicht schaffen.
Kann ich das nicht an irgendeinen Festplatten-Wechselrahmen anschließen.
Die haben ja keinen Anschluss.
Sie haben ja nicht solche Anschlüsse.
Die haben einfach einen Anschluss für einen Strom und einmal, und halt zwei, drei, vier, fünf SATA-Ports.
Ja, es gibt Verlängerungskabel, aber die passen nicht da dran.
Ja, das habe ich auch gedacht.
Eine Verlängerung passt da nicht dran.
Zeige ich euch warum.
Hier, guckt mal.
Das ist ein SATA-Verlängerungskabel.
Mit dieser Seite müsste man die ja eigentlich da dran stecken.
Das Problem ist, erstens, du stößt, ich kann jetzt, kann man dieses Foto irgendwie mal so groß machen, dass man, du stößt hier gegen diesen Zacken.
Also, du stößt, Moment, wie rum kommt es denn überhaupt?
So rum.
So rum, also das da.
Das da kommt quasi auf die Seite dann.
Also, das hier ist eigentlich zwar so ausgehöhlt.
Das ist, das ist eigentlich so ausgehöhlt, dass das hier drüber passt, aber trotzdem sieht man, der Zacken geht über, geht, geht hier oben drüber raus.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist ja hier, seht ihr es ja, hier in der Mitte, hier in der Mitte ist ja Plastik.
Und hier in der Mitte müsste eigentlich die andere Seite rein.
Bloß dort, wo Plastik ist, ist hier auch Plastik.
Das heißt, hier macht man Plastik auf Plastik und es passt nicht rein.
So, was ich jetzt gemacht habe ist.
Ich habe zum Glück noch eine andere, eine andere Verlängerung da.
Ich habe hier, also ich habe hiervon ein paar da und ich habe davon ein paar da.
So, das sind nicht genau die, aber sehen so ähnlich aus, ja.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt mal anstatt am Adapter rum zu wursten, an dieser, an diesem Ding rum gewurstet.
Aber es kommt aufs gleiche raus.
Und zwar habe ich jetzt folgendes gemacht.
Ich habe hier, dieses, das was übersteht abgebrochen.
Diesen, diesen, diesen spitzen Knüppel.
Den Knüppel habe ich abgebrochen, auf der einen Seite, dann ist das flach, dann passt das.
Und auf der anderen Seite, auf der anderen Seite habe ich vom Kabel das Plastik Ding abgebrochen und glatt geschliffen.
Ja, was ist glatt geschliffen?
Ich habe, ich habe es einfach abgebrochen und das was noch übrig war, weggeschmirgelt, ja.
Ähm, jetzt passt das.
Und das funktioniert auch.
Aber, es ist jetzt irgendwie nicht schön, oder?
Es ist, also.
Ich meine, da, ich muss, ich muss quasi Adapter, sowohl SATA Kabel umbauen, beziehungsweise abschneiden oder, oder wegschmirgeln, dass es passt.
Es funktioniert.
Also ich habe es ausprobiert.
Ich mache jetzt hier das SATA Kabel dann im Endeffekt dran.
Mach es, äh, mach es an die Festplatte und, und die Festplatte kriegt Strom vom Netzteil.
Das funktioniert überhaupt kein Problem.
Ähm, aber schön ist es nicht.
Hat irgendjemand von euch da eine andere, eine schönere Idee?
Ja, ja, ja.
Schmitty 2802 Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön, Poggas.
Huge Sub.
Kann dir eine Leiterplatte machen?
Kostet nicht viel, aber dauert zwei Wochen, bis ich die von China eingeflogen habe.
Ah, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Das verbrauche ich nicht.
Also, ich kann ja, ich kann ja mit Leben, dass das abgebrochen ist.
Ich dachte, da gibt es vielleicht irgendwas Fertiges.
Ich dachte, da gibt es irgendwas, irgendwas Fertiges, dass ich einfach nur das falsche, den falschen Typ, den falschen Typ SATA Kabel gekauft habe.
Ich meine, eigentlich, eigentlich bräuchte ich ein SATA Kabel mit einem Stecker, das eben nicht diese Befestigungsdinge hat.
Ich meine, so zum Erklären, wofür das da ist, ne.
Ich habe ja immer noch nicht meinen Heimautomatisierungs-Server wieder aufgebaut.
Und bei der Gelegenheit habe ich mir gedacht, ich kann das jetzt ja mal endlich probieren.
Ich habe mir ja damals alle, alle möglichen Sachen bestellt.
Ich habe mir hier beispielsweise diese...
Die ganzen 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarten bestellt.
Hier, so, ne.
Äh, Mellanox, also, Dinger.
Äh, das, sowas da, oder, oder auch, ich habe mir ja ein paar 10 Gigabit-Karten bestellt.
Bei der Gelegenheit wollte ich das jetzt mal ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert, eben mit, ähm, 10 Gigabit.
So, das heißt, ich mache da mein Heimautomatisierungs-Zeug drauf und, ja, Lightning-Style, genau, sowas.
Zeig mal den Wechselrahmen, den du benutzen willst.
Ja, ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher.
Also, was ich aktuell zum Testen ver...
Oh, fuck, wie heißt denn das Ding?
Muss ich mal gucken.
Gucken, ob ich das Ding finde.
Ne.
Äh.
Wie haben wir...
Oh, fuck.
Ne.
Äh.
Sag dir, sag dir, klar.
Wenn ich, wenn ich das...
Oh, ich glaube, ich finde das auf der Seite nicht.
Ja, so in der Richtung.
So in der, so in der Richtung.
Bloß halt mit mehr.
Ja.
Zeig das mal von hinten.
Zeig mal das Ding von hinten.
Ja, so, so ungefähr.
Ja, das, das, das stimmt jetzt.
Das ist jetzt zwar komplett, äh, viel zu groß, ja.
Aber hier sieht man es, hier sieht man es doch ganz schön, ne.
Du hast hier unten, hast du einmal oder zweimal Strom-Connector.
Und dann hast du in der Mitte die SATA-Anschlüsse.
So.
Und um...
Das da, um, um quasi hier...
So.
Wie gesagt, mit meinem abgeschnittenen und abgefeilten Kabel funktioniert das Ganze.
Aber es ist nicht schön.
Deswegen habe ich gedacht, vielleicht hat irgendjemand eine klare Idee,
wie man das Ganze schöner machen könnte.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob ich irgendwelche Subs vergessen habe.
Illuminato
subscribt.
Poggers. Habe ich gar nicht gesehen, oder?
Huge Sub.
Ich habe auch den ganzen Chat jetzt nicht gelesen.
YouTube hat mir letztens wieder
ein Gartenstellensvideo empfohlen. Wann kommt ein neuer Teil?
Im Winter vielleicht.
Schön, dass du letzter Zeit so aktiv bist.
Ja.
Das finde ich auch.
Es ist schön, dass ihr noch so viel am Start seid.
Ehrlich gesagt, ein Kabel
in ein Kabel stecken.
Ja gut, was willst du sonst machen?
Also, hat von euch
auch keiner irgendwie eine glorreiche Idee.
Das ist natürlich blöd.
Ich habe gedacht, wir haben absolut einen Big Brain Chat heute.
Anscheinend
sind noch nicht genug Leute
subscribed, dass der IQ weiter steigt.
Vielleicht klappt das ja im Laufe
des Streams noch.
Wir wissen ja, dass jeder Sub
den Durchschnitts-IQ
um 5 Punkte steigt.
Und vielleicht schaffen wir es ja heute
mit noch ein paar Subs, dass die IQ so weit steigt,
dass wir eine Antwort darauf finden,
wie ich diesen Adapter auf diese Backplane
gestapselt kriege.
15 Uhr läuft mein Sub aus.
Top.
Poggers.
Letztens hat sich
irgendjemand unter dem Video beschwert.
Ich glaube unter dem
Windows 98 Video.
Also unter dem da.
So nach dem Motto, dass das irgendwie
irgendwie unerträglich wäre,
dass ich so
Internetsprachemäßig rede.
Und da habe ich mir so gedacht, Moment,
wo sind wir hier denn?
Könnte das sein, dass wir vielleicht im Internet sind?
Nein, das kann nicht sein.
Oh.
Mach mal auch Windows 2000
oder XP. XP wollte ich machen.
Windows 2000 ist glaube ich
nicht so interessant.
Blob-Version Vista.
Ey, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das schreibe ich mir mal auf.
Vista.
Doch, ich kann, ich, ich, ich, ich mache echt mal ein Video
zu Windows Vista, weil
da kann ich irgendwie,
da kann ich sozusagen quasi das, das meist
gehasste Windows oder irgendwie sowas
in Titel schreiben. Da stehen die Leute drauf.
Der Bildschirmarbeiter schreibt,
er kann mir gerade nicht ganz folgen, weil
das ist doch die Rückseite.
Vorne kommen die Platten rein, die Rückseite wird
ans Mainboard oder in die Red-Kontrolle angesteckt.
Wieso willst du hinten eine USB-Platte anstecken?
Tja.
Das ist die Frage, ne?
Das ist die Frage.
Und wie so vieles
ist die Antwort da drauf
Big Brain.
Also, mein Mainboard
hat bloß zwei SATA-Anschlüsse.
Und ich habe
ein Gehäuse
mit einer Backplane drin. Das ist ein billiges Gehäuse,
weil ich will das ja, ich will mal gucken.
Ich wollte ja schon die ganze Zeit gucken, dass ich
möglichst billig den 10 Gigabit nass bauen kann.
Möglichst billig.
Das ist nicht unbedingt was zum Nachmachen, weil ich muss schon
ein bisschen Kompromisse machen, aber ich will es einfach mal ausprobieren.
Und mein Mainboard,
also sprich, das Mainboard,
was ich habe, wo ich halt
eine 10 Gigabit-Karte reinmachen kann, hat selber
nur zwei SATA-Anschlüsse.
Die zwei SATA-Anschlüsse werde ich verwenden
für
einen SATA-Anschluss werde ich verwenden
für die Systemplatte.
Und
die anderen zwei
Anschlüsse brauche ich halt noch für die Platten.
Oder wenn es sogar vier sind,
muss ich das ja auch machen.
Deswegen muss ich mindestens eine Platte
per USB anschließen.
Und
deswegen brauche ich halt
irgendwie SATA
USB auf SATA, allerdings
nicht auf SATA kompletten
SATA-Stecker mit allem,
sondern halt nur auf SATA, normales SATA-Kabel,
was ich dann in die Backplane stöpseln kann.
Funktionieren tut das. Ich habe das ja mit dem
abgefeilten Kabel probiert.
Wäre
falls weh, zwei Monate,
Pog.
Dankeschön, Poggers.
Plus 20 IQ?
Nein, nein, nein, so einfach ist es nicht.
So einfach ist es nicht.
Plus 50, äh, äh, plus 5.
Ja, ich meine, sonst wären wir ja ab,
sonst würde unser Kopf explodieren
demnächst durch die ganzen
Subs. Da haben wir zu viel IQ.
Hardy, Stufe 1, abonniert drei Monate.
Dankeschön, Poggers.
Oder Coggers müsste man hier
an der Stelle sagen, weil es dreht sich ja.
Was SATA-Controller eigentlich?
Also, ich habe
so einen USB auf SATA-Adapter
gekauft, das Ding hier.
Und jetzt ist die Frage,
wie kriege ich das SATA von hier
an meine, an meine
SATA-SAS
Backplane dran?
Die Backplane,
beziehungsweise der Wechselrahmen
für die Festplatten, der hat ja nur
normale SATA-Anschlüsse.
Das heißt, ich muss von da irgendwie
da rein.
Das ist nicht so einfach, wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Ein SATA-Hub.
Gibt es sowas?
SATA-Hub? Das gibt es nicht.
Es gibt SATA-Multiplexer.
Das wäre eine Option, ja.
Das Problem ist, sowas haben wir im letzten
Stream sogar ausprobiert. Allerdings haben mich da
die Chinesen gescamt.
Ich habe was gekriegt, was nicht das Canvas
draufsteht. Deswegen habe ich mich jetzt,
bevor ich jetzt nochmal AliExpress-China-
Kram bestelle, habe ich mich dafür entschieden,
wir machen, ich nehme den
naheliegenden Anschluss, nämlich
einfach USB.
Und ist auch kein Problem, weil die ganzen
USB-Adapter, die man mittlerweile hat,
die unterstützen alle quasi SATA,
also im Prinzip SCSI
über USB.
Das ist halt USB 3.0, ist das Standard.
Das ist hier diese UASP
Geschichte.
Das ist quasi SCSI-Kommandos
über USB.
Das heißt, es macht eigentlich gar keinen großen Unterschied,
ob man die Sachen jetzt per SATA oder per USB anschließt.
Die Frage ist nur, oder das Problem ist,
wie kriege ich den Mist von hier
hier dran?
Das ist echt das Problem.
So, der Eichler
ist zwei Monate am Start auf
Stufe 1. Dankeschön, Poggers.
Mark Zuckerberg,
der Gründer, ich sage das
übrigens absichtlich so, das ist genauso, wie ich auch
Amazon sage.
Wobei, ich finde
gerade Zuckerberg ist eine schöne
Betonung. Der Gründer
von Facebook ist rot-grün-blind und hat
deshalb als Facebook-Farbe blau gewählt.
Jetzt kommen hier die krassen
Facts.
Was mache ich?
Das frage ich mich auch.
Abonniert per Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
XLXS ist neu am Start. Moin.
Ähm, sowas.
Oh, wir haben schon die ersten.
Ja, sowas.
Aber diese Adapter,
ja, solche Adapter habe ich auch gefunden,
aber diese Adapter
haben halt alle Kack-Bewertungen
und wenn man sich ein paar Meinungen dazu
anguckt, sind die halt Crap.
Solche Normen.
Diese Adapter sind halt eigentlich ganz gut.
Habe ich ja auch schon. Zwei Stück da, die funktionieren ja auch gut.
Diese anderen Adapter sind halt Müll.
Den gleichen habe ich auch schon gefunden.
Stripes 007 Stufe 1.
Drei Monate schon.
Selber Adapter bauen.
Ja, das ist richtig
Massive Brain.
Warum kaufst du nicht einfach eine USB-PCI-Karte
im Server rein?
Weil der keinen Platz hat.
Der einzige PCI-Express-Slot,
den das Mainboard hat,
der einzige PCI-Express-Slot,
äh, das ist das falsche.
Gibt es das noch als B?
Der einzige PCI-Express-Slot,
den das Board hat,
ist belegt mit einer 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte.
Deswegen ist es doch gerade
so kompliziert.
Ich bin nicht selbst schon auf die Idee gekommen,
einfach
eine PCI-Karte zu kaufen.
Statt irgendwie so eine riesen Akt zu machen.
Klar, auf die Idee bin ich auch schon gekommen.
Alternative Idee, neues Mainboard.
Auch nicht möglich, weil es gibt keine
Mainboards, die das alles haben.
Das einzige
Mainboard, was es gibt,
was theoretisch die Möglichkeit
bieten würde,
hat nur ein Dual-Core drin und das reicht nicht.
Ein anderes
Mainboard, was ich eigentlich viel lieber verwenden
würde, hat sogar eine mit 4
PCI-Express-Lanes angebundenes
ähm,
äh, PC, äh,
Dings hier, Interface.
Das Problem ist, dass dieses Board nicht
ITX ist und das PCI-Express
auf der Rückseite hat.
Also sprich, das kriegt man in gar kein
in gar kein normales Gehäuse rein.
Also, was die sich bei dem Bau
gedacht haben, verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, das Board an sich ist ja ganz cool, aber
Hallo, wo sind die Fotos dazu?
Ähm,
das Board an sich ist eigentlich ganz cool,
das Problem ist nur, dass der Shit auf der
Rückseite ist.
Ich meine, warum?
Das kannst du in kein normales Gehäuse einbauen.
Hier ist PCI-Express drinnen.
Das heißt, du müsstest hier einen Adapter drauf
machen, wo dann ein PCI-Express-Slot
hinkommt.
Das kannst du in kein normales Gehäuse einbauen.
Warum baut man so einen Müll?
Ich meine, okay, ich weiß, weil man es kompakt
machen will, aber ich meine,
jetzt mal nicht ernsthaft, dieses komische
Crap-Gehäuse oder
ein ordentliches Gehäuse für
äh, für ITX-Boards.
Was bevorzugt man wohl?
Also ganz ehrlich,
ich sehe mich nicht dieses Crap-Gehäuse
hier verwenden. Ihr meint, das sieht aus,
als hätte ich das aus meinem eigenen 3D-Drucker
irgendwie mit 0,3mm
Quick-Dingsprint
rausgehauen.
Okay, ne, ehrlich gesagt sieht es besser aus.
Es sieht schon besser aus, als aus meinem
eigenen 3D-Drucker.
Aber trotzdem, sowas bescheuertes,
wenn ihr ein ganz normales Gehäuse verwenden könnt,
guckt euch das mal an.
So, und deswegen,
das ist eigentlich das beste Board
für mein 10-Gigabit-NAS.
Rein von der technischen Spezifikation her,
das hat einen Dual, es hat einen Quad-Core,
es hat PCI-Express mit 4
Lanes angebunden. Ich meine, das hier unten ist zwar
ein M2-Slot, aber ist kein Problem.
Macht man halt von einem Adapter rein, wo ein PCI-Express
Slot dann oben drauf ist.
Die einzige Scheiße ist, dass es falsch
rum ist. Es ist falsch rum. Es passt in
kein Main, es passt in kein Gehäuse rein.
Ja, das ist ein M2,
aber das ist ein M2 mit 4 PCI-Express
Lanes. Kannst einen Adapter
reinmachen und dann kriegst du PCI-Express raus.
Das ist nicht das Problem, das
funktioniert auch. Aber es ist unten!
Es ist unten! Und es passt damit in kein
Gehäuse rein. Deswegen muss ich
dieses Board verwenden.
Übrigens, hier hätte ich das gleiche Problem mit den 2 SATA
Anschlüssen gehabt. Deswegen verwende
ich dieses Board. Das hat zwar nur
2 PCI-Express
Lanes in dem
16-fach Slot, aber
das reicht halbwegs
für eine 10-Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte.
Ich meine, ich krieg da zwar kein Maximum
von 10 Gigabit
aber so 7
Gigabit krieg ich da
ungefähr durch.
So 2 Drittel ungefähr krieg ich da durch.
Das reicht. Mehr geben
die Platten ja eh nicht her.
Das ist mein Problem.
Und deswegen
brauch ich irgendwas, wie ich
noch mehr SATA-Platten
anschließen kann. Und die nächste Sache
ist dann, welche SATA-Platten
will ich mir überhaupt holen?
Weil
wenn man das hier mal
filtert, Preis
pro Terabyte
dann sind 8 Terabyte das, was
am attraktivsten erscheint, aktuell.
170 Euro, 8 Terabyte.
Man muss aber dazu sagen,
ich habe ja schon 13 Terabyte
Platten.
Allerdings
wollte ich die, ich will ja
eigentlich nur 2, ich will es ja viel einfacher bauen.
Ich will ja kein RAID 5 mehr machen.
Wie bei dem anderen. Allerdings
sind die
ein bisschen anderweitig
verplant. Ich würde gerne eine
der 10 Terabyte Platten bei mir in Desktop-Rechner
machen, weil ich komme mit meinen 6 Terabyte
an die Grenze, manchmal
wenn ich einfach lange Sachen aufnehme.
Und meine Downloads sind
komplett auf der
Platte, weil wozu soll ich die auf die SSD speichern?
Die ganzen Videoaufnahmen
und Zeug kommen immer direkt auf die Platte drauf.
Das heißt, da würde ich gerne
eine 10 Terabyte Platte in meinen
Desktop-Rechner machen, die von denen
ich jetzt habe. Und die anderen beiden
zusammen, die sind ja dann bloß noch 10 Terabyte
groß. Und ich hätte gerne
schon ein bisschen mehr. Deswegen habe
ich mir überlegt, ich könnte
mal gucken, was beispielsweise größere
Platten kosten. Da ist mir aufgefallen,
der Preis explodiert.
Ich verstehe immer noch nicht, warum du an die Backplane
eine USB-Platte anstecken willst.
Ich will nicht an die Backplane
eine USB-Platte anstöpseln.
Ich möchte SATA, also
USB-SATA, also ein
USB-SATA-Adapter
an die Backplane anschließen,
weil ich nicht genug SATA-Anschlüsse auf dem Mainboard
habe. Ganz einfach.
Ich will keine USB-Platte an die Backplane
anschließen. Ich will einen zusätzlichen
SATA-Anschluss.
Doch, dadurch habe ich
mehr Ports. Ich habe zwei SATA-Anschlüsse
auf dem Mainboard.
Und ich habe intern
nochmal noch zwei
USB-3-Anschlüsse auf dem Mainboard.
Wo ich einfach zwei
USB-3-Anschlüsse
zu SATA-Adapter
machen kann.
Eine USB-Platte kommt ja eh
dran für Backup. Natürlich habe ich
mehr Ports.
Ich habe zwei SATA-Ports
auf dem Mainboard
und nochmal zwei SATA-Ports
über USB. Wie nein?
Willst du mich skamasen vom Namen her?
ETF, Alter.
Nee, deswegen will ich das.
Das heißt, ich habe dann
Alter. Ich habe dann hier
zwei Anschlüsse.
Ich habe hier zweimal SATA.
Und ich habe hier zweimal
SATA. Ich habe so einen
Aufstecker, der
quasi hier reinkommt und da sind dann oben drauf
direkt zwei USB-3-Ports.
Also ich habe dann quasi hier zweimal
SATA und hier zweimal SATA.
Deswegen brauche ich dann einen SATA-Adapter,
der
einfach nur SATA-Kabel
kann. Ja, wo das ordentlich dranpasst.
So, und bei
Festplatte habe ich mir überlegt,
ob ich mir nicht vielleicht die hier kaufen sollte.
Ich meine 320 Euro.
Das ist ein Preis
von etwas über dem,
was quasi die
besten, so die
besten Preis-Leistungsplatten kosten.
So 2 Euro pro Terabyte ungefähr drüber.
Aber dafür 14 Terabyte.
Und die sind aktuell
im Vergleich zu dem, was halt da
nachkommt, relativ günstig.
Relativ, ja.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einfach
zwei Stück davon kaufen soll.
Oder vielleicht sogar,
vielleicht kaufe ich mir sogar 3,
dass ich einen RAID 1 machen kann. Ich weiß noch nicht genau.
AI, warum AI?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich,
weil AI cool ist.
Brauchst du PCI-Express 4? Nein, nein, nein.
Ich brauche PCI-Express 2.
Also 4 kann das Ding gar nicht.
Wenn das Ding PCI-Express 4 hätte,
wäre es auch kein Problem, weil
die 10 Gigabit-Netzwerkkarte
würde dann ohne Probleme mit zwei
Lanes volle Pulle laufen.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
14 Terabyte, oh megaloll. Warum?
Das ist doch nice. Gut, dass es mittlerweile
gibt.
Guck mal, warum ist denn das so günstig aktuell?
Das fällt. Guckt euch das mal an.
Das huge
huge price fall.
Ich glaube, den muss ich gleich mal bestellen.
So, also ich bestelle mir zwei.
Erstmal und das werde ich
dann so machen.
Die 2 Terabyte
Samsung SSD gibt Systemplatte
und die
14 Terabyte
Platte hier, die gibt
Platte
für
Rest, für alles, was nicht
irgendwie schnell sein muss, was nicht System ist,
was nicht Container ist oder
VM oder sonst was.
Zum rein dumpen Zeugs.
Und die 2.
14 Terabyte Platte
entweder mache ich ein RAID 1
draus, was den Vorteil hat, dass ich
mein 10 Gigabit Lesegeschwindigkeit
ein bisschen besser ausnutzen kann.
Oder aber ich mache es ganz
primitiv, die eine Platte rein
und die andere Platte einfach nur
nachts für einmal Backup.
So.
Jetzt habe ich euch alles erzählt.
Ach ja und ich habe mir überlegt, ich mache
ein Video, wie ich das Ding zusammen baue.
Ich mache ein Video davon, wie ich das Ding
zusammen baue und
erzähle dann auch ein bisschen was zu
einer Trashfestplatte quasi.
Aber ich
sage dann auch gleich dazu, dass es nicht unbedingt
zum Nachbauen gedacht ist, auch wenn
ich denke, dass das Preis leistungsmäßig
echt unschlagbar günstig ist
für eine 10 Gigabit NAS.
Würde ich nicht unbedingt empfehlen
nur auf das allerbilligste,
also nicht nur versuchen um das billigste
zu bauen.
Beispiel ist das Gehäuse, was ich habe.
Das ist zwar ein 19 Zoll REC Gehäuse,
aber der Wahnsinn ist es jetzt nicht.
RAID 0? Ne, RAID 1.
RAID 1 meine ich.
RAID 1 ist auch schneller als
eine einzelne Platte.
Nicht im Schreiben, aber im Lesen.
Weil du mit RAID 1 von beiden Platten lesen kannst.
Was du mit RAID 1 nicht machen kannst,
ist schreiben auf beide Platten
schneller.
Aber lesen kannst du, weil ich meine,
ist ja ganz logisch, die Leseperformance
von RAID 0 und RAID 1 ist ungefähr das gleiche.
Du kannst bei beidem parallel
die Datei von zwei Datenträgern lesen.
Ne, ne, nicht VM.
Also wenn ich überhaupt
auf dieser Kiste eine VM laufen lasse,
dann ist es KVM.
Oh, ich glaube, ich habe übrigens
die falsche Kategorie eingestellt.
Habe ich Just Chatting oder habe ich
Science and Technology?
Just Chatting, ah ja, ok, sehr schön.
Ja, ich glaube, dann bestelle ich mir
zwei von Mine Factory.
Warum hat Mine Factory eigentlich so
viele Bewertungen?
Ich habe mit denen eigentlich immer gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Wehe, man hat Probleme und die sind offenbar
vorprogrammiert.
Oh, Alter, too long didn't read.
Ja, ja, ja, was geht mit den Leuten ab?
Braucht ihr euch die halbe Lebensgeschichte
der Leute um eine Bewertung zum Job?
Na doch, warum nicht?
Vielleicht gibt es ja mehr Details.
Habe ich irgendwelche Subs übersehen?
Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Du hast mit Mine Factory schlechte Erfahrungen.
Warum?
Aber ganz davon abgesehen,
eigentlich ist es doch überhaupt
kein Problem.
Weil wenn man Probleme
mit Mine Factory hat, man kann doch,
das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren,
sagen wir mal in Warenkorb,
ähm,
bestellen zur Kasse und dann gucken wir mal,
guck mal, die haben,
die haben doch Paypal Checkout,
oder?
Kann man nicht direkt mit Paypal?
Kann man nicht mit Paypal Checkout
machen direkt?
Weil wenn man mit Paypal
oder Amazon Pay bezahlt,
also wenn man über dieses Paypal Checkout
und Amazon Pay bezahlt,
doch als Gast,
und dann?
Weil dann kann ich doch eh sagen,
hier, ich habe nie etwas erhalten oder es ist kaputt.
Ich habe mal
so ein kaputtes Rack
bekommen
und da war die Glasscheibe
vorne gebrochen
und der Shop hat sich nicht gerührt
mit
wie es aussieht, mit
zurückschicken bzw. mit ersetzen, hat sich nicht gerührt.
Da habe ich bei Paypal einfach so
einen Konfliktlösungsfall aufgemacht
und habe gesagt, hier, ähm,
ich habe jetzt die angeschrieben, melden sich nicht
und, ähm,
man kann ja so einen Konfliktschlichtungs-
Dingsbums da bei Paypal machen
und das hat dann dazu geführt, dass
am letzten Tag, wo das Ganze ausgelaufen wäre
und Paypal sich drum gekümmert hat,
ähm,
haben sie sich gemeldet und haben gesagt, ey, ich krieg's Geld
wieder, aber ich soll das Rack, wenn es geht,
wegschmeißen, weil es ist, sie sind zu teuer
das zurückzuschicken.
Hast du studiert oder eine Ausbildung?
Ich habe eine Ausbildung gemacht.
Hatte vier RX 5700,
die defekt waren bei Mindfactory, bin dann in
den Laden meines Vertrauens gegangen
und habe mir einen Nvidia gekauft.
Okay.
Das ist halt echt Pech, ne?
So, wir gucken jetzt ein bisschen Videos, weil heute ist Sonntagmorgen,
eigentlich wollen wir aufwachen
mit der Musik los.
Eigentlich wollen wir ja aufwachen, sondern mit was fangen wir an?
Mit was fangen wir an?
Fangen wir mit der History of
Speedrun
äh, Rainbow Road Mario Kart an?
Fangen wir mit dem aktuellen
Quake World Record Speedrun an?
Oder fangen wir mit, ähm,
spielen Leute
immer noch World at War an?
Oder, ich habe noch ein paar mehr Sachen zur Auswahl,
äh, die habe ich aber noch nicht aufgemacht,
habe ich in mein Tablet, ähm,
dann haben wir noch zur Auswahl,
haben wir noch
zur Auswahl,
das war's für mich, äh,
must buy,
was die, die drei must have Features,
wenn man sich den Staubsauger-Roboter kauft,
oder aber,
was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Ich habe mir ein paar Videos aufgeschrieben, die wir gucken können.
Oder,
oder
Call of Duty Lost its
Identity.
Aber das ist schon von 2015.
Also,
Rainbow, okay,
Quake, World at War,
Staubsauger,
Quake, Gott, okay,
ähm, dann fangen wir zuerst damit an,
dann fangen wir zuerst damit an,
und, weil
das geht bloß 11 Minuten, weil die anderen Videos sind ein bisschen
länger, da geht's, es geht 30 Minuten, das geht,
fuck, Alter, 47 Minuten!
Was, guck mal Every Programming
Tutorial von Jumbo, du musst mir mal ein Link schicken.
Ähm,
wir müssen eh ein Fortunate Video gucken,
pro Stream, der Typ ist halt echt nice.
Ich glaube, das hier ist eh fake,
die Anzeige.
World at War.
Today we're gonna be finding out
if people still play this game online.
I know the last time I played it,
I did find some lobbies.
Das Problem ist, dass die Lobbys in World at War total
verhexort sind, beziehungsweise
total viele Cheater-Lobbys am Start sind.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich keine normalen Lobbys mehr.
And we still have to check in.
I don't know about you guys, but Call of Duty World at War
was the first Call of Duty I ever played.
Here's down in the comments below.
I'm curious to see when you guys all started.
Hopefully we're able to play some multiplayer.
Have some nostalgia here.
Drop a like if you guys do enjoy the video.
Subscribe if you guys are brand new.
Anyways guys, let's get right into the video
and let's try destroying.
Alrighty yo, so we're able to find the game.
It's only 4 vs 5 at the moment.
Gonna eventually see if things pick up here in this game.
Hopefully it turns into a full lobby.
That would just be great.
We have taken the lead.
Das Voice-Acting Call of Duty World at War,
für die 5 fand ich auch cool.
MP5 Beste.
Das Ding war so...
MP5 Juggernaut Extended Max.
Oder Double Tap.
Double Taps, auch okay.
MP40 Juggernaut Extended Max.
Artillery, not that it'll get many kills,
but screw it, I'll just throw it in.
I can just hope it gets one kill.
I doubt it'll get any kills,
to be completely honest.
Der 5er Killstreak hat gesagt.
Oh gosh, that was close.
I love Double Tap on the MP40, bro.
It melts.
We got some dogs,
3 of them on the other team.
Denk mal, in World at War waren die Hunde noch 7er Killstreak.
I don't know how this is gonna work out.
Die waren richtig gut.
Der Host hat einfach mal die Konsole ausgeschaltet.
Das ist eine interessante Frage.
Der Kios sagt...
Irgendwas habe ich im Hals.
Wann lohnt es sich am meisten einen neuen PC zu kaufen?
Also zum Beispiel von Release neue Hardware.
Da sag ich gleich was zu.
Zombie Head is just tilting his head, bro.
Look at him.
I really just got dogs and the game lags out like that.
I don't know what's going on at this point.
Wahrscheinlich Hacker-Lobby am Start.
Okay, wir gehen von vorne los.
Sehr fair.
What is he doing? He's growling.
Ich würde eher sagen,
der Hunde ist geklitscht.
Really?
Oh my gosh, man.
Again? Again?
Okay, es ist nicht mehr spielbar.
I love it so much. Thank you very much.
Another huge problem with World at War is
I don't understand why they still have the DLC maps
allowed to be searched if you don't have them.
Wow, that guy sniped me from behind.
Stimmt. Das Cod hat ja diese nervigen Panzer.
These tanks are nothing compared to the tanks in Modern Warfare.
Right past me.
So, I mean, at least I'm still lucky enough to find some lobbies here.
This is dope.
Wait, there's another guy. I'm about to get killed by a tank.
Alright, at least I got the recon plane.
Und die Panzer waren richtig dumm.
Did I really just spawn right there behind that guy?
Now, on a real note, I keep seeing the player count decrease
as the night goes on.
I truly don't understand why they search DLC lobbies
when half the lobby doesn't even have the DLC.
I saw a guy around this way.
There we go.
I don't know where they're coming from now.
Alright, I guess a teammate of mine got dogs.
What are these guys doing?
Is there just not a lot of people on the other team?
Oh, there's two guys on the other team, bruh.
There's legitimately two people left.
A third one just connected.
I should get in the tank for old time's sake.
But, uh, is this one gonna blow up?
Not just yet. Oh, fuck.
Post-ended game, bro.
Aber die Tanks waren
Die Tanks waren richtig dumm in Confrontation.
Die Me...
Cod hatte, Cod 5 hatte mit,
also nicht alle, aber mit
auf jeden Fall die,
will ich sagen die besten Maps,
aber die Maps die sind vorne mit dabei.
... that when the host left the game or dashboarded this game
is just like...
Holy crap.
Oh, schöner Genoobtube.
We're noobtubing.
We're noobtubing, bruh.
Holy crap.
No way, Jose.
Alright, I'll take that STG
Das Ding heißt Gewehr.
The Goo-Goo-er.
Na gut. Ganz ehrlich, ich hab's
auch nicht so mit englischer Aussprache. Warum sollten die das
da mit deutscher Aussprache haben?
The Goo-Goo-er.
Weggetriggert.
Goo-Bär. Genau.
Goo-Bär.
Übrigens.
Wisst ihr, was ich da
damals immer gedacht hab?
Ich fand, das Hunde-Icon sieht aus wie
ein Bär.
Ich find, das sieht aus wie ein Bär, das Hunde-Icon.
And look who it is.
Is this guy dead serious?
I really can't tell.
What are you doing, man?
You can't hide from my dogs.
Oh, that martyrdom.
I miss when this game was actually populated, bro.
When this game was in the
Honestly, most Call of Duty games in the Prime
was so lit, dude.
Climbing up. Climbing up. Climbing up.
Ja, außer in den letzten paar.
Also in den letzten vier Jahre, oder so.
I'm about to be in war right here.
Kid ran up the stairs.
Ex-Sprayt.
Die Waffe waren auch echt nice.
Ob er MP40 eindeutig
OPste Waffe überhaupt war.
One more for the dog.
That's my teammate called an artillery on our head.
And we got dogs.
I probably could have called them my artillery,
but I'm an idiot.
I'm gonna wait here for a swift
second, because I know these guys are running up.
Oh.
Weck.
Beschreckt.
And the artillery only kills me.
For real now?
Are we for real now?
I think it's great how most of the guns in this game
are all, like, usable and stuff.
I was gonna say there's not a single gun
that most people only use.
Aber die Maps sind wirklich gut.
I was like, yeah, everyone does kind of use the MP40.
But in a casual game like this,
you'll see mostly every single gun.
Gott, ein Moorball.
Oh.
Weggecampt.
I call them dogs, and they get not a single kill right now?
Really?
Die Waffe sackt.
Die sackt richtig.
Die sackt.
Zumindest run-and-gun-technisch
ist das die coolste Crap-Waffe gewesen.
Der Noob-Tuber, Alter.
Da oben war doch einer.
Was guckst du da?
Äh, wir gucken gerade Fortun8.
Ja, Fortun8.
Wir gucken eigentlich immer jeden Sonntag
ein Video von ihm.
Macht einfach nice Videos.
Am besten war die russische Win-Musik in World at War.
Die russische Win-Musik war beste.
Du, du, du, du.
Seitdem kenn ich auch die russische Nationalhymne.
Oh, es geht ja noch weiter.
Oh, Thompson-Extended-Maps.
Auch übelst nice Map.
Napalm-Chunky.
Was ist das für eine Frage, Alter?
Max, welche Waffe hast du in Fortnite am besten gesuchtet.
Am meisten gesuchtet?
Big-Brain-Frage.
Die Thompson war übelst nice, da konntest du auch aus der Hüfte schön draufsprayen.
Ja, I am Jinxed lol, hättest du das ganze mal auf der Xbox gehabt, dann hättest du es
als Backwards Compatibility mäßig spielen können.
Oh, Artillerie gestreckt, ja die Gegner sind auch absolute Bots, ja das macht der auch.
Call of Duty, das ist das, was ich auch bei Modern Warfare sage, Call of Duty macht nur
richtig Spaß public, wenn du ab und zu machst.
Wenn du nur mal gegen richtige Bobs spielst, nur dann macht das Bock, wenn du permanent
immer am Limit spielst und gerade mal so eine ULV hinkriegst, ist halt nicht so spaßig.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie die Granate rausgeleckt ist, das war eine halbe Sekunde.
Ja, das kommt doch.
Ja.
So, Achtung.
Schreck!
Die Videos von dem sind einfach nice.
Oh.
Ja.
Nee, warum sitzt der in der Ecke, weil Leute den Cod in der Ecke sitzen?
Was geht mit dem da oben ab?
Erstmal schön weggetropshottet.
Du spielst doch Battlefield 3, müssen wir eigentlich mal wieder?
Das hat geleckt, geleckt ohne Ende.
Oh.
Erstmal schön durchgesprayt durch die Wand.
Dogs am Start.
Die Commander Krieger, Wowzis.
And alright, that guy just really loves his flamethrower and I don't blame him.
Using a flamethrower in this game is really fun.
I think my dogs get me some kills and we get the time limit here and reach the score limit.
I'm gonna get a nice double triple kill right here.
I'll take one, whatever.
You're dead.
You're dead. Let's go.
Is there still someone else in here? Really?
My boy, what are you doing posted up in the corner like that?
Nope. Nope. The hipfire on this gun is so nasty.
Yo, I enjoy hipfire with mostly all the guns in this game. If you use steady aim, it's so good.
Oh, jetzt werden sie aber weggesprayt, ey.
The game's gonna lag out? Are you kidding me?
Wow, WTF? Alter, ist ja gut.
I don't even remember what my score was. We were just doing so nasty.
Oh, wow. That is just so lame, man.
Alright, guys.
Hopefully you did enjoy the video.
If you did, be sure to drop a like, subscribe if you guys are brand new.
World at War, yes, there are still some players playing it.
We got 153 left online.
Okay, nice. Die Videos von ihm mag ich echt.
Also, wie gesagt, ähm, guckt mal bei ihm vorbei.
Subscribert.
Er macht schöne Videos.
Nicht viel rumgemache, er einfach Gameplayer und gut ist.
Wart ihr nicht für Inscope 21 verantwortlich?
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ähm, der, der Niko hat zwar auch bei uns früher mitgemacht, ja,
aber...
Das hat er schon...
Dafür sein Erfolg ist er schon selbst verantwortlich.
Das ist ja auch so der originale...
So der originale, für mich so der originale Lifestyle-YouTube-Channel.
Das war ja der erste, der zumindest in Deutschland mit dem Kram so richtig angefangen hat.
Und der war damals schon nicht immer so richtig glücklich
mit so seriösem kommentieren und labern zu Games.
Der wollte schon immer so ein bisschen verrückteres Zeug machen und
das hat jetzt ja auch ganz gut funktioniert.
Aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich habe jetzt lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Das ist ja auch nicht unbedingt Content, der mich jetzt großartig anspricht.
Wieso heißt Max hier nicht Max?
Das habe ich schon öfters, öfters erklären müssen.
Und zwar, weil ich den Channel eigentlich zum Privat-Twitch-Gucken erstellt habe.
So, und jetzt hatten wir ja hier die Frage...
Ähm...
Moin Max von Kios.
Wann lohnt es sich am meisten, einen neuen PC zu kaufen?
Also zum Beispiel vor Release neue Hardware oder nach Release und dann die alte günstig oder eher in Zukunft investieren
und die neue holen.
Ganz ehrlich, nach 20 Jahren PC gibt es dazu aus meiner Sicht eigentlich nur eine Antwort.
Du solltest dir einen neuen PC holen, wenn dir dein Alter zu langsam ist.
Und nicht warten.
Es sei denn, es gibt irgendwas, was du mit dem aktuellen nicht machen kannst.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir jetzt irgendwas bauen will
und ich brauche dazu unbedingt irgendwie, weiß was ich, ähm...
Mehr SATA-Anschlüsse oder was weiß ich, was die aktuellen Boards alle nicht haben
oder irgendwie...
Na, SATA-Anschlüsse ist blöd, die Boards haben massig SATA-Anschlüsse mittlerweile.
Ich brauche irgendwie USB 3.2 oder USB 4 oder...
Ich brauche irgendwas, was das Aktuelle nicht hergibt.
Dann würde ich warten.
Ähm...
Aber ansonsten...
Oder PCI-4, genau.
Falls man das brauchen soll.
Also, dann würde ich warten, da bleibt dann ja auch nichts anderes da übrig.
Aber ansonsten...
Würde ich immer dann kaufen, wenn ich es brauche.
Und aktuell...
So.
Und aktuell würde ich mir einen Ryzen-Desktop zusammenbauen.
Es gibt auch keinen Grund zu warten, weil es war eigentlich so gut wie seit langem nicht mehr,
preis-leistungsmäßig sich ein gutes Desktop-System zusammenzubasteln.
Du kaufst dir einen aktuellen Ryzen.
Die Boards sind auch ganz gut, relativ teuer.
Ähm...
RAM ist günstig zurzeit.
Festplatten, haben wir gesehen, sind auch günstig zurzeit.
Ähm...
Das einzige, was richtig teuer ist, sind Nvidia-Grafikkarten.
Aber ansonsten...
Gibt es jetzt eigentlich keinen besseren Zeitpunkt, sich irgendwie einen neuen PC zu kaufen.
Also, ich würde das jetzt machen.
Und ich würde es generell auch immer jetzt holen.
Der Plan war eigentlich, auf GTA 6 zu warten.
GTA 6 zu warten und das Setup darauf anzupassen, damit man das gut zocken kann in guter Grafik.
Also sollte GTA irgendwann demnächst rauskommen, sag mal so innerhalb 1-2 Jahre,
dann wirst du das auch auf dem PC gut spielen können, wenn du dir jetzt einen guten kaufst.
Aber es steht ja noch vollkommen in den Sternen, vor allem, wann PC-Release ist oder so.
Oder?
Ja.
Das heißt, du müsstest jetzt ja noch jahrelang warten.
Ich würde aktuell trotzdem eine Nvidia-Karte kaufen, ja.
Ich würde eine 2000...
Also wahrscheinlich würde ich mir wieder mal eine 2080 TI holen.
Einfach, weil ich das schnellste habe.
Aber wahrscheinlich, preis-leistungstechnisch ist eins oder zwei Stufen drunter.
Irgendeine 2070 Super oder eine 2080 Super.
Wahrscheinlich deutlich sinnvoller.
Äh, es gibt...
Centillion, es gibt eine uralte Version von dem Memeboard.
Gibt es auf GitHub.
Aber die kann kaum was von dem, was die aktuelle kann.
So, jetzt gucken wir uns mal an,
was die Must-Have-Features sind,
wenn man einen Staubsauger-Roboter kauft.
Der macht übrigens auch ziemlich gute Videos,
wenn es um das Thema Heimautomatisierung oder ein bisschen Gebastel geht.
Nicht alles.
Beispielsweise will er den Leuten immer erzählen,
dass es ja nicht schlimm ist, die Daten irgendwo in die China-Cloud zu legen und sowas.
Ja, da bin ich persönlich anderer Meinung zu.
Aber an sich sind die Videos echt nicht schlecht.
Also mal davon abgesehen,
ich kaufe mir jetzt nicht noch einen Staubsauger-Roboter.
Ich habe zwei und das reicht.
Scientific Tests.
Big Brain Time angesagt, Leute.
Ja, zwei Stück.
Einen Eufy 11 irgendwas.
So ein ganz billiger mit...
Billiger.
Also von den Features billiger mit Infrarot-Fernbedienung.
Und...
einen...
Xiaomi...
Xiaomi heißt das übrigens.
Es heißt nicht Chaiomi, sondern es heißt Xiaomi.
Ähm...
Roborock S50.
Geflasht natürlich.
Mit Custom-Firmware.
Xiaomi.
Xiaomi, ja.
Aber ich merke es mir immer, dass man das wie Show-Me ausspricht.
Ist ja ganz einfach.
Show-Me.
Das Tool, das dir die Nachrichten auflistet.
Oh ne, das habe ich glaube ich nicht auf Twitch...
äh, auf GitHub.
Ja, Sbarro habe ich, habe ich gesehen.
Mit AI.
Robotic Vacuums are the single most life-changing smart home product.
Da ist er. Den habe ich.
Den habe ich, ja. Den da.
...on the market today.
And I firmly believe that if you don't have one,
you should immediately move it to the top.
Hat er recht. Hat er recht.
I love smart home tech.
But the hard truth is that we were able to survive...
...before automated light switches and curtains...
Wie viel Aufwand ist es, einen Staubsauger zu flashen?
Also der S50 ist ziemlich einfach.
Du brauchst einen Raspberry Pi für.
Und du machst das anhand einer Anleitung.
Du machst das anhand der Anleitung hier.
Das ist die Custom-Firmware für den Staubsauger-Roboter.
Und die haben hier eine Anleitung.
Die machst du einfach durch.
Und dann hast du deinen Staubsauger geflasht.
Ist relativ einfach.
Man darf aber nicht zu zimperlich sein, ja.
Also, wenn man sich nach jedem abgesetzten Kommando Gedanken macht,
dauert das zu lange.
Und wahrscheinlich verkackt man es auch irgendwie.
Man muss einfach in your face.
Ja.
Auch mal ignorieren, wenn eine Fehlermeldung kommt.
Einfach weiter.
Wieso flasht man seinen Staubsauger an,
dass man zum Beispiel keine China-Cloud mehr benutzen muss?
...simply standing up and flipping a switch or pulling a cord.
The reason why robotic vacuums are such a great invention
is that they take something you should be doing every day,
like cleaning your floors,
and they actually do it.
If you're already happily cleaning your floors daily,
good for you.
Niemand, niemand, der arbeiten geht,
macht täglich seinen Boden sauber.
Ganz davon abgesehen, ich mache eigentlich so gut wie niemanden den Boden sauber.
Das ist einer der Gründe dafür.
But if you aren't,
you'll be amazed at the increase in quality of life
that a robotic vacuum can give you.
Not only will your floors be cleaner,
but you'll notice less dust on your furniture,
less allergens in the air,
and indirectly have your robotic vacuum...
Ja, kann ich machen.
Aber das müssen wir in einem der nächsten Streams erstmal
ein bisschen umprogrammieren,
weil das Ding hat kein Interface für Configs,
sondern hat eine Konfig-Datei ein
und hat hardcoded mein Username überall drinnen.
Das müsste man nochmal machen.
Ich schreib mir das mal auf.
Oder muss ich das Fiverr...
Eigentlich wollte ich heute das Fiverr-Video machen.
Das Video on stream?
Ne, das geht nicht.
Stimmt.
Ja, das ist wirklich praktisch.
Also so wie man das jetzt hier sieht,
so sieht das in dem Webinterface auch aus mit Custom-Firma.
Das Schöne ist, dass die Custom-Firma für den Staubsauger
mittlerweile mehr kann,
dass die Custom-Firma für den Staubsauger
mittlerweile mehr kann als die offizielle Firma.
Aber es sieht im Prinzip genauso aus.
Ich hab euch ja meinen schon mal on stream gezeigt.
... specific needs.
I've gathered four great vacuums to compare
from all different price ranges.
I'm doing them through a series of tests
to get some cold hearted...
Lohnt sich das für ne Einzimmerwohnung?
Ja, ich find sogar dafür lohnt sich das.
Du stellst das Ding einfach so ein,
dass das... also entweder
hast du die Möglichkeit festzustellen,
wenn du rausgehst,
dass er dann anfängt,
oder du sagst zu ner gewissen Uhrzeit,
wenn du immer nicht da bist.
Für ne Einzimmerwohnung kannst du dir allerdings auch
nen relativ...
Da ist es egal, ob der jetzt besonders clever
den Raum reinigt oder den Raum abscannt
Da kannst du dir auch irgendwie so nen
Eufy, so nen günstigen Eufy oder so kaufen
für ne Einzimmerwohnung.
Aber, wenn du so einen hier zum Beispiel
günstig bekommst, find ich lohnt sich das
für ne Einzimmerwohnung. Ich mein,
Einzimmerwohnung ist ja immer ein Einzimmer.
Da ist auch ein Bad dabei, da ist wahrscheinlich
auch ne Küche dabei. Das sind ja eigentlich
drei Zimmer. Und dafür lohnt sich das,
find ich.
Das Ding kann wischen.
Wobei, ich benutze das
Wisch-Feature nie.
Der S50 kann wischen.
Und der hat auch nen Schutz dagegen,
dass das Wasser ausläuft, falls er hängen bleibt.
Ja, das ist den, den ich hab.
Allerdings,
500, in der Regel kannst du ja
Dollarpreise immer ganz gut zu Euro-Preisen
äh, umwursten. Nur mit dem
Unterschied, dass es, dass du das Ding
teilweise für unter, oder
sag mal für 300, 320 Euro
kriegst. Also 500 ist
viel, viel, viel zu teuer.
Wir können ja grad mal gucken. Ja.
Ne?
Also.
Kann man machen. Ist übrigens ziemlich guter Preis
dafür.
500 Dollar ist, äh,
übertrieben. Den würde ich, für 500 würde ich
den auch nicht kaufen.
Gibt's heute Abend nochmal einen Stream. Wieso ist
heute Abend irgendwas?
Hab ich irgendwas vergessen? Ist heute Abend irgendwas?
Das Video ist neu.
Ha! Nicer Testaufbau, das hat er cool
gemacht. Das find ich nice.
Was, heute Abend mehr Zeit als
jetzt? Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das war nicht der
S50, okay. Sieht aber echt
ähnlich aus.
Ja, das stimmt.
Magst auch Switch Prime,
dankeschön. Huge.
Big Brain. Wieder IQ vom Chat gesteckt.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das ja nachher noch raus.
Mit dem SATA-Adapter.
Wenn der IQ
immer weiter steigt.
Kios hat übrigens, äh,
100 Cent gespendet.
Vielen Dank für den, hat mir sehr geholfen.
Das ist, das ist nice. Ähm,
Sir Ife
subscribed Prime. Dankeschön, Poggers.
Prime, ni-ni-ni-nice
subscribe.
...on the market that you should steer clear of.
Random Navigation is the least
efficient cleaning method, where a vacuum just
bounces around your house.
Ja, aber das ist sowas, wo ich sagen würde, ey,
für eine Einzimmerwohnung kann man das machen, so ein random, äh,
Ding. Na, ich hatte mir ja davor
den, den allerersten Staubsauger-Roboter
den ich mir geholt, geholt habe.
Top.
Äh, 11? Guck mal.
Der kostet, den kriegst du aktuell für 143 Euro.
Der kann nicht wischen.
Der fährt auch random.
Ist aber relativ klein. Passt unter alles
drunter. Leon Gerdes
Twitch Prime, zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Pog, jetzt geht's aber ab hier. Nice!
...Subscriber!
...wald und Furniture,
until it runs out of batteries and it goes back to its charger.
For reasons that I'll discuss later,
I think these vacuums will cause you more
frustration than they're worth. So go ahead and cross
them off your list. High-end robotic
vacuums, like the new iRobot Roomba
i7 and S9, have
...Gründer? Was ist
das denn? Ist das irgendein neues Twitch-Feature?
Das ist, wenn man von Anfang an
mit dabei war, oder was?
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es dafür jetzt ein neues
Icon gibt. Alter, Wahnsinn.
Twitch macht immer neue
Sachen.
Die ersten 25... Oh, Big
Brain! Wahnsinn. Ich hab keine Ahnung,
ob man da nicht irgendwas spielt. Da muss ich mir was überlegen.
Da muss ich mir...
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob man dafür überhaupt irgendwas einstellen kann.
Also quasi
Custom Emotes von meinen
vier Emotes von 25 Slots oder so.
Ich hab's ja immer noch
nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt, ey. Ich krieg da
ein richtig schlechtes Gewissen mit den Emotes, ey.
...Gamer-based
Navigation. But I'm really not sure
why iRobot is clinging to this technology.
Not only is camera-based
navigation worse when it comes to accuracy,
but it also requires the lights to be on
in the room. And in my opinion,
it opens up a huge... LIDAR ist Laseranmessung.
Ja, das ist das
Beste. Das ist wirklich das Beste.
...of privacy issues.
When you have a WiFi-connected camera
taking a tour of your house every day. Das stimmt.
LiDAR-Robots, on the other hand, use a
spinning infrared laser to generate an
accurate map of your home and provide
the most efficient cleaning path while avoiding
obstacles. And they do it without all those
messy privacy concerns. Combined with
their companion apps, LiDAR-Robots
also give you the ability to virtually block
off areas of your home where you don't want
your vacuum to go. Which is an absolutely
must-have feature in my opinion,
and it will help you avoid the tangles and
hang-ups that used to be associated with robotic
vacuums. These no-go lines... Ja, das
kann man im Webinterface,
seitdem ich den geflasht hab,
kann man das alles im
Webinterface einstellen.
Das ist nämlich ganz praktisch.
Zum Beispiel, wenn
ich den unten reinigen lasse,
da ich ihm dann sage, hey, da wo die Schuhe drin
stehen, da kannst du halt, da könnt
er halt theoretisch reinfahren, da musst du
nicht sauber machen und sowas. Das ist echt praktisch.
Zones are slowly coming to
camera-based navigation robots, but they
aren't quite as accurate and they are more
prone to failure. All the robotic vacuums
that I'll be testing in this video are equipped with
LiDAR. But if you're looking at another brand
or model, an easy way to tell if it's a LiDAR
robot is by looking for the raised
circle on the top of the robot that houses
the splitting laser. So, if the most
important feature can be found on vacuums
that differ in price by more than
$500, what does that mean
your extra money is actually getting you?
At this point, I'd be remiss if I didn't mention
another amazing YouTube channel that's
dedicated specifically to vacuum reviews.
And it's called Vacuum Wars.
His reviews are unbiased and
quantitative, and he's got this whole
vacuum testing thing down to a science.
However, being somewhat a scientist myself,
I recognize the importance of
vacuum testing.
Es gibt wirklich einen Channel, der sich
mit Staubsaugern testt.
Wahnsinn. Den Channel muss ich gleich mal
subscriben.
Der muss gleich mal subscribed werden.
Mal nachher gucken, was
der zu meinen zwei
Staubsauger-Robotern sagt.
Zeig mal Subscriber hier.
Geh weiter.
Das ist übrigens ein wichtiger Punkt.
Teppich
das Teppich
extra
extra gründlich saugen.
Und zwar, das hat der S50, hat das
auch als Feature. Der erkennt, wenn er
auf dem Teppich ist, wahrscheinlich wie
schwergängig die Rollen sind oder so, keine Ahnung, wie die das machen.
Und dann schaltet er hoch.
Was natürlich praktisch ist, dann verbraucht er nur mehr
Akku auf dem Teppich. Und ich muss euch ehrlich
sagen, im Wohnzimmer, so sauber
war mein Teppich noch nie.
Seit ich
den Staubsauger-Roboter habe.
Der ist halt relativ
langsam und gründlich und fährt dann teilweise,
wenn er das, ähm,
checkt dann auch langsamer drüber.
Manche Sachen doppelt.
Das lohnt sich.
Mit der Kastenfirma, jaja, auch damit.
Damit haben oftmals
welche Probleme, die bleiben dann irgendwie
dran hängen oder so. Oder manche
saugen sich, äh, so diese
Fransenteppiche, saugen sich Dinger ein
und kommen dann nicht weiter.
Das sind die
meisten gewöhnlichen Fehlern.
Der S50 schlägt sich ganz gut.
For instance, the Ecovacs Osmo 950
was by far the most aggressive
robot, while the Roborock S50
and the D-Bot 900 were much more
gentle, which resulted in some difficulties
navigating over the large thresholds.
My guess is in the future this aggressiveness
Der Akte, ich finde sowas braucht auch jeder
mittlerweile.
Das ist wirklich so praktisch.
Der S6, den
S6 würde ich mir nicht kaufen, weil ich glaube der
S6 ist der Nachfolger vom S50,
den kann man nicht flashen mit Kastenfirma, das musst du
mit China Cloud betreiben und
da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
...configurable in the app. But for now, if you want
a gentle robot that isn't likely to knock over
dull furniture, the S50 is
probably your best bet.
And if your house has a lot of different flooring levels
with moderately sized thresholds,
then the Osmo 950 will navigate
your own needs.
If your house is relatively easy to navigate,
you can save some money by getting the D-Bot 900.
And don't forget, if you do have
one specific trouble area in your house,
you can always use the app to create a
photo line to keep the vacuum out of trouble.
Speaking of apps, my final
consideration for choosing a robotic vacuum
is connectivity. One of my
favorite parts about my vacuums is that
I never see them doing their jobs.
My downstairs vacuum is triggered by our
bedtime routine with a 30 minute
delay. So the family is all upstairs
and fast asleep by the time it leaves the dock.
Ich würde den überhaupt nicht nachts
putzen lassen, ich lasse den immer tagsüber putzen.
Each vacuum has slightly different integrations
and I've included the most common smart
home hubs and control mechanisms in this
car. I've also rated the complexity of
getting these vacuums integrated with different
smart home systems on a scale of...
Kingwall fragt, was so ein Staubsauger
groß nach China schicken soll.
Naja, es ist ja nicht nur, dass der Staubsauger
was nach China schicken kann.
Es ist so, du brauchst die passende App
dazu auf deinem Smartphone.
Was im Endeffekt schon heißt,
du musst quasi die App
bei dir auf dem Smartphone verwenden.
Und natürlich, du hast quasi ein Gerät,
was quasi Remote-Zugang
hat aus irgendeiner
Cloud bei dir im WLAN
stehen, was potenziell auch auf alles andere
im WLAN zugreifen kann.
Also ich würde es gar nicht so sehr sehen,
was das Ding theoretisch nach China schicken könnte,
sondern was vielleicht jemand
bei dir im WLAN machen könnte.
Oder was man abgreifen könnte.
Man weiß es ja schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Ich will denen auch gar nichts unterstellen.
Ich gehe mal sogar nicht mal davon aus,
dass da irgendwelche wichtigen
oder irgendwelche illegalen Sachen getrieben werden.
Glaube ich noch nicht mal.
Aber
ich kann einfach in meinem Netzwerk keine Geräte haben,
von denen ich nicht weiß, was sie machen.
Und außerdem, wenn dein Internet-Zugang
nicht funktioniert oder die App Probleme hat
oder du irgendwelche anderen Probleme hast,
kannst du deinen Staubsauger-Roboter
nicht verwenden, weil der wirklich für jeden
misst, außer die eine Taste,
die vorne drauf ist.
Und dann aber auch nicht richtig
Cloud-Zugang braucht.
Ja, hier. Beste.
Krasse Firmware.
Wo hat das gelinkt?
Jetzt sale mal, was der jetzt nicht gelinkt.
Ich wollte ein paar Dinge erzählen, die schön zu haben sind, aber nicht kritisch in meiner Meinung.
Zuerst ist die Batterielife.
Der Ecovacs Osmo 950 hatte eine absolut verrückte Batterielife,
die das Wettbewerb aus dem Wasser ausgelöst hat.
Aber all diese LiDAR-Navigation-Roboten haben eindeutige Recharge- und Resumabilität,
wo sie dein Haus in ca. 20 Minuten sauber machen werden.
20% Batterie, dann zurück in den Charger, den Top-Off der Batterie, und dann zurück in den genau gleichen Spot.
Wenn du ein sehr großes Single-Floor-Haus hast, benötigst du immer noch eine Batterie,
weil du generell eine single Mapping-Runde machen musst,
bevor die Recharge- und Resumabilität operativ ist.
Auch wenn dein Haus groß genug ist, dass du mehr als eine Recharge- und Resumabilität benötigst,
kann das bedeuten, dass ein Single-Floor-Haus länger als 8 Stunden dauern wird,
was die Grenzen steigern wird, um dein Haus zu cleanen, während du weg bist.
Mein zweites interessantes, aber nicht nötiges Feature ist das Moppen.
Der Osmo 950, Tuya LDS und RoboRod,
alle haben Moppen-Effekte.
Könnte er, also putzen mit Lappen, könnte er, habe ich aber noch nie benutzt.
Nee, der kann bei mir nicht die Treppe hochfahren.
Ich setze ihn oben hin, aber ich habe ein Skript.
Nochmal, das ist wieder auch das Tolle von Custom-Firmware.
Ich habe ein Skript, der die Maps für oben und für unten laden kann,
wenn ich ihn hochhebe.
Big Brain.
Der lädt dann, wenn ich oben bin, die Map für oben.
Und für unten die Map für unten.
Oder aber ich kaufe mir zwei Sauger. Ja, das wäre natürlich auch möglich.
Sie werden eine kontrollierte Anzahl an Lippen auf ein Moppen-Pad verwenden
und dann den Boden in einer kontrollierten Art und Weise waschen.
Es ist keine großartige Moppen-Erfahrung, aber es ist auch nicht das Schlimmste.
Das größte Problem ist, dass der Pad keine Kraft verwendet.
Habe ich schon nie ausprobiert.
Es ist die Möglichkeit, deine Flügel sehr leicht mit einem dampfen Stuhl zu waschen.
Wenn du alle Holzflügel hast, ist Moppen definitiv etwas zu schauen.
Aber in meinem Fall haben meine Stuhlflügel
Karpfen zwischen ihnen.
Und das verhindert, dass ich meinen Robotik-Vakuum
auf einer unerwarteten Moppen-Runde sende.
Und wie ich schon einige Male in diesem Video erwähnt habe,
Zwei verschiedene WLAN. Keine Ahnung. Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich weiß es. Keine Ahnung. Warum zwei verschiedene WLANs?
Die absolut beste Sache an diesen Dingen ist,
dass sie all ihre Arbeit ohne deine Input machen.
Und das bringt mich zu meiner letzten,
Ei, der Rap-Piedler.
Zwei Monate.
Sub.
Nicht mal Prime-Sub. Richtig Sub, Alter.
Subscriber.
Dankeschön.
Ers.
Ja. Siehste? Mein S50 mit Custom-Firmware hat sowas auch.
Flame Haze. Zwei Monate. Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Subscriber.
Okay, so what's my final verdict?
If you just want the best, most hassle-free vacuum that will do a superb job cleaning your floors,
the Ecovacs Osmo 950 is an easy pick.
But I think Ecovacs have really priced themselves out of the market with their own D-Bot 900.
For basically a quarter of the price, the D-Bot 900 gives you similar suction, cleaning ability, scheduling and mapping.
As I mentioned, the D-Bot 900 is going to do best if your floors are level without too many transitions.
But other than that, it is an absolutely impossible price to beat.
The two-year vacuum would also be really interesting if it wasn't for the D-Bot 900.
It's just too good for too cheap.
If you're a lifelong tinkerer and you won't be able to just leave your vacuum alone,
then you probably won't be able to clean your floors.
I mean, so richtig, also wirklich so perfekte Eckenreinigung, keine Ahnung, aber ich habe damit keine Probleme.
Also, die kriegen in der Regel die Ecken ganz gut sauber mit.
Die Ressourcen sind nicht so schlecht.
Was für eine Bitrate.
7 MBit.
Oh, nice Video.
Ich kann dem eigentlich nur zustimmen.
Das Wichtigste bei einem Staubsaugerroboter ist tatsächlich, dass man sich möglichst wenig darum kümmern muss.
Einmal aufgesetzt sollte das Ding reinigen und gut ist.
Beste.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir den Quiz.
Quake-Speedrun.
Entleert das sich selbst?
Nein.
Das nicht.
Den Staubs... also den Staubbeutel
musst du schon auch selbst ausleeren.
Das wäre cool, wenn auch
einer mal einen Staubsauger-Roboter erfindet,
der sich selbst sauber macht.
Zweiter Sonntag-Stream, ja. Wahnsinn.
Poggers.
Aber Quake ist immer noch geil zu gucken.
Wie oft muss man den leeren nach Fläche...
Boah, ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich lasse den meistens 2-3 Räume irgendwie
oder sagen wir mal 2-3 Räume putzen
2-3 Räume am Stück
dann schicke ich ihn wieder zur Station
und leere ihn halt aus.
Also, ich kann das echt schwer einschätzen.
Aber es passt schon recht gut was rein.
Es ist ja auch wichtig, dass man
die Staubsauger-Roboter immer
regelmäßig laufen lässt, dann ist es nicht so viel auf einmal.
4-3-Beste.
Das Schöne ist,
das Schöne ist, dass Quake
einen Replay-Modus hatte.
Slipgate.
Das klingt unanständig.
Das war ein Riesen-Schein.
Das war ein Riesensprung von Doom zu Quake.
Ich meine, es war schon ein recht großer Sprung von Wolfenstein zu Doom,
aber von Doom zu Quake, ich würde sagen, ab Quake sahen quasi viele Spiele so aus, wie sie aussehen.
Bloß immer weiter verfeinert, aber es ist einfach, finde ich, ein Weltenunterschied dazwischen.
Allein schon, dass du nach oben und unten gucken kannst.
Dass du überall 3D-Models hast.
Quake hat ein paar sehr wichtige Features von Doom übernommen.
Der erste war das Endscreen, das die Zeit zeigte, in der das Level veröffentlicht wurde.
Das machte das Real-Time-Score-Tracking eine Brise
und beugte für Wettbewerb, um zu sehen, wer jedes Level in der niedrigsten Zeit veröffentlicht werden konnte.
Der zweite war die Fähigkeit, Runden zu ermorden,
indem man Inputs hervorruft und sie in Form von Demos verwendet.
Diese Demos konnten schnell über das Internet gesendet werden und wieder auf...
...die bei ganz vielen neuen Spielen nicht mehr drin ist, obwohl es eigentlich kein Problem wäre.
Überlegt euch mal, sowas wie Demos ist im Prinzip ja die Grundlage für sowas wie den Kinomodus oder den Replay-Modus.
Und jetzt überlegt mal, wie ewig es gedauert hat, irgendwie zweieinhalb Jahre oder ewig auf jeden Fall,
bis Overwatch den Replay-Modus bekommen hat.
Ein Spiel, was als große E-Sport-Geschichte vermarktet wurde und bis vor kurzem keinen Replay-Modus hatte.
...ein Computer mit Quake installiert.
Demos sind großartig und es ist ziemlich großartig,
Runden zu sehen, die über 20 Jahre alt sind, mit so viel Klarheit.
In den 90ern war es eigentlich ziemlich schwierig, Videos von Konzolen zu erzeugen und resultierte meistens in schlechter Qualität.
Videofile sind viel größer als Demo-File und weil die meisten Internet-Händler auf Dial-Up waren
und wollten, dass die Files klein waren, wurden Videos so kompressiv, dass ihre Qualität enorm verringert wurde.
Zum Beispiel, seht euch hier ein Bild von GoldenEye 007 aus dem 19. Jahrhundert an.
...schau euch hier ein Bild von GoldenEye 007 aus dem 19. Jahrhundert an.
....schau euch hier ein Bild von GoldenEye 007 aus dem 19. Jahrhundert an.
Nun, seht euch ein Bild von einem Quake Speedrun von getan ober 90ern они nicht gecheckt wurden.
Nun, seht euch ein Bild von einem Quake Speedrun von getan 0u 06 von 1997, zwei Jahre zuvor.
successively
Gillian
Ich hab dann passt den Moment geguckt.
das heißt wirklich Daim also
Willen
aиты
Rд
Ich glaube, das sieht viel einfacher aus, als es ist.
Ich glaube, das sieht wirklich viel einfacher aus, als es ist.
Hast du dir schon mal Elementary OS angesehen? Ja, sogar on stream.
Nice!
Ah, sehr gut, Timo.
Speed Demo Archive, gab's da.
Speed Demo Archive.
Ja, Speed Demos, genau.
Flame Haze, das ist eine Linux-Distribution.
Ja, zu einer Zeit, wo man sich das noch angucken konnte.
Ja.
Ich guck, ähm, GameStorm Quick guck ich nicht mehr, seitdem es ab Only Chat ist.
Ich hab nicht...
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, also ich kenne Quake 1 nicht sonderlich gut.
Half-Life 1 beispielsweise kenne ich auswendig, aber Quake 1 habe ich nie großartig gespielt.
... ist, dass wir auf der EZ-Difficulty spielen werden.
Wenn ihr meine vorherigen Doom-Videos gesehen habt, werdet ihr erinnern, dass Doom Speedrunnern...
... Speedrunnern auf die schwersten Schwierigkeiten spielen.
Quake ist ein bisschen anders in diesem Bereich, als die meisten...
Ja, ja, seh ich auch so, SamolonXD, ich mein, ohne mich jetzt zu sehr da über GameStorm Quick auslassen zu wollen,
aber ich finde, Sub-Only Chat ist ein absolutes Unding, ähm, und vor allem, übertreiben sie es in manchen Sachen.
Ich hab gelesen, TriHacks wäre irgendwie gebannt, also quasi einer der Größten und bekanntesten Speedrunner,
letzten Jahre über wurden Leute teilweise sehr fragwürdig gebannt, ähm, alles, was irgendwie entfernt, irgendwie ein bisschen gemimt oder lustig ist, ist gebannt, ähm,
auch egal, ob es unter der Gürtellinie ist oder nicht, wenn man, wenn man sagt, hey, das ist eindeutig unter der Gürtellinie, das wollen wir nicht, verstehe ich, ja,
aber zum Beispiel war vor ein paar Jahren, war, war irgendein, ein Mädel da, was Pokémon, äh, glaube, gespeedrunnt hat, und da haben alle dann im Chat geschrieben, das wäre das Pokegrill,
und das hat sie ja sogar selbst, sogar selbst...
selbst hat sie sich danach irgendwie im Subreddit geschrieben, so, hallo, ich bin das Pokegrill, und so, hatte keiner, die hatte überhaupt keine Probleme damit irgendwie gehabt,
und heute wirst du gebannt, wenn du das Wort Grill schreibst, äh, das ist echt übertrieben.
Die populärsten Kategorien sind auf der einfachen Schwierigkeit gespielt, das ist, weil Monster eine Menge Glück in den Rennen vermitteln,
und wie wir sehen werden, ist das Quake-Movement extrem technisch und mappiert, also je weniger Glück es braucht, desto besser.
Außerdem werden wir die Kategorie schauen, wo das einzige Ziel ist,
um so schnell wie möglich das Ende des Stages zu erreichen.
Deshalb werden wir die Geheimnisse und Monster, die möglich sind, ignorieren.
Ja, Evoli, sag ich doch gerade.
Samusk, Reimer, Samusk, na, na, na, na, na.
Drei Monate schon, huge.
Ja, also, dass Tri-Hex gebannt wurde, ist auch so ein Ding, ähm, das verstehe ich nicht so ganz.
Ähm, der wurde bei Twitch gebannt, was ich auch schon ein bisschen fragwürdig finde.
Ich meine, er hat mit ein paar...
Er hat mit ein paar Kollegen zusammen, ähm, bekannten Freunden gespielt, und da ist ihm das, das, ne, ich, ich sag's jetzt nicht, wer weiß ja nicht, ähm, ein Wort rausgerutscht, was nicht so nett ist.
Allerdings, ähm, ich denke mir, dass schon viele Leute sich unter, unter Freunden beleidigt haben, gegenseitig, ja, ähm, und es nicht quasi als Beleidigung so quasi so, so, so, so, so, um den anderen jetzt wirklich niederzumachen benutzt haben.
Also, weißt du, was ich...
Du, wie, wie, wie, guck mal, wenn ich mit dem Friseur spiele, wir schweißen uns auch manchmal dummes Zeug an den Kopf, ja, da hat sich keiner Gedanken drum gemacht.
Also, es war nicht abwertend gemeint, dass er dafür gebannt wurde, fand ich auch schon ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Ähm, dass er jetzt noch quasi als, ähm, dass er jetzt quasi dann auch noch von GameStop und Quick gebannt wurde, weiß ich nicht.
Patrick, was machst du da gerade?
Ich will kein Sub, ich will kein Sub-Only-Chat, mach wieder an.
Once starting the level and heading down the first hallway...
...we encounter our first door on the left.
It's important to point out that there is no activate button in Quake.
Wie macht man den, macht den Kramer wieder weg?
Ach so, okay.
...in Quake. Doors are activated by proximity and buttons are activated by making physical contact with them.
This means there is no need to time frame perfect inputs in order to open doors and press buttons as soon as possible, as you would in Doom.
After a short elevator ride, we encounter our first enemies as well as a bridge.
Through the next door lies a T-Junction with a dead end on the right.
There's an explosive crate here that will explode when shot.
Heading around the next corridor, we find a piece of sloth quake.
Doors are activated by proximity and buttons are activated by making physical contact with them.
Nice to, Sub-Scrimer!
This means there is no need to time frame perfect inputs in order to open doors and press buttons as soon as possible, as you would in Doom.
After a short elevator ride, we encounter our first enemies as well as a bridge.
Huge Sub!
Big IQ!
...through the next door lies a T-Junction with a dead end on the right.
There's an explosive crate here that will explode when shot.
Heading around the next few corners, we find a pit of slime blocking access to the rest of the level.
The portion on the right will extend a ledge once activated, allowing us to cross.
The next section contains a spiralling ramp housing three buttons.
All three of these buttons will need to be activated in order to open a door lying at the base of the ramp.
...the next section contains a spiralling ramp housing three buttons. All three of these buttons will need to be activated in order to open a door lying at the base of the ramp.
Einmal durch die geöffnete Tür, eine kurze Halle ist alles, was uns von der letzten Raum entfernt, die das Slipgate besitzt, das wir benutzen, um den Stag zu verfolgen.
Das Slipgate wird durch Kontakt aktiviert, also ist es nicht notwendig, einen letzten Knopf zu drücken.
Der erste, auf dem Weltrekord gedreht wird, geht zurück zum 20. August 1997.
Der Runder Gunnar Andre Moe hat einen Zeitraum von 30 Sekunden gesetzt.
Leider ist dies die einzige Demo, die für immer verloren worden ist, also werden wir nicht die Runde sehen können.
Aber es war nicht lange, bis Gunnar das Absolut gemacht hat, als er einen 29-Sekunden-Rund am 19. September 1997 erreicht hat.
Dieser Runde ist extrem primitiv.
Keine der zukünftigen Techniken haben den Skandal des Weltrekords.
Der Runde ist extrem primitiv, voll die Kacknungs, Alter.
Der übelste Runde, 29 Sekunden.
Voll primitiv.
Nicht, dass ich es auch so ansatzweise so schnell hinkriegen würde, oder?
Das ist ein interessanter Punkt, weil es den aktuellen Geschwindigkeit des Quake-Guy in Sekunden pro Sekunde darstellt.
Wenn man in einer rechten Linie läuft, ist die Geschwindigkeit, die Quake-Guy erreicht hat, 320 Sekunden pro Sekunde.
Mit diesem Runde als Benchmark, wirst du die Bewegungen oder Techniken, die mehr Geschwindigkeit erzeugen können, identifizieren können.
Okay, das ist interessant.
Am 26. Januar 1998, hat ein Spieler mit dem Namen Burn & Son den Runde in 28 Sekunden erreicht.
Hier sehen wir das erste Implementieren einer echten Geschwindigkeitstechnik.
Wall-Running.
Aha.
Durch das Strafen auf einer Wand, kann man einen ganz großen Boost in der Geschwindigkeit erreichen.
Man wird schneller, wenn man an der Wand ist.
Der Design des Quakes-Levels ist ziemlich komplex.
Warum ist das 4 zu 3? Weil Quake 4 zu 3 ist.
Aber man kann sehen, wie Burn & Son jede kleine Gelegenheit nehmen, Wall-Running zu ihrem Vorteil zu verwenden.
Am 24. April 1998 sah der Spieler Will Marsh den Rekord auf 27 Sekunden.
Will hat sich von einer sehr primitiven Technik gewöhnt, die sich bezeichnet wie Zig-Zagging.
Durch die schnellen Alternativen von Strafe-Button, kann man die Geschwindigkeit von ca. 400 Units pro Sekunde erreichen.
Will hat diese Technik so viel wie möglich genutzt, aber er hat trotzdem versucht, Wall-Running zu vermitteln, wenn es möglich war.
Seit diesem Zeitpunkt war das Speed-Running von Quake immer noch unglaublich einfach.
Aber eine Technik wurde gerade entdeckt, die das Landscape von Quake für immer drastisch verändern wird.
Am 30. Mai 1998...
Der Speedrunner von Quake.
Ilka Kurkela.
Wird diesen Rundung erreichen.
Hu!
Die Quake-Sau, Alter!
Ah, der jumpt jetzt drüber!
Das haben die anderen nicht gemacht.
26...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo der aktuelle World Record ist.
Der Technik, die als Strafe-Jumping genannt wurde, wurde genutzt.
Ohne zu weit in die Beleuchtung von Quake-Movements zu gehen, erhielt der Spieler eine viel höhere Frequenz.
Es wurde bereits seit 1997 bekannt, dass man mit Strafe-Jumpen und dem Maus in Richtung des Strafe-Jumps die Frequenz erweitern kann.
Aber das war nicht unbedingt so hilfreich, da man, sobald man die Frequenz stoppt, sofort wieder 320 Units pro Sekunde zurückdrehen könnte.
Das ist...
Ach, das ist der Grund, warum man fürs Bunny-Hoppen bzw. fürs Strafe-Jumpen so wackeln muss die ganze Zeit.
Das habe ich mich in Half-Life und CS schon immer gefragt, warum man so wackeln muss.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass es quasi aus dem gleichen Grund ist.
Weil es ist ja im Prinzip auch Quake.
Ich weiß nur, dass es mit Wackeln funktioniert.
Ich wusste nicht, dass das der Grund ist.
Wegen der Friktion, die durch das Laufen auf dem Boden erzeugt wird.
Aber man kann diese Mechanik nicht nutzen, indem man am Ende des Rundens springt.
Während Airborne, wird keine Friktion an Quake-Guy angewendet.
Das bedeutet, dass er die ganze Frequenz seiner Frequenz behalten wird, wenn er springt.
Das ist natürlich der Grund.
Deswegen, wenn man sich beispielsweise mal einen Half-Life-Speedrun anguckt...
Die machen ja permanent so hier.
Mit der Maus.
Äh, was ist der Grund?
Der Grund ist, dass du mehr Speed kriegst, solange du dich drehst.
Ich muss mal kurz was gucken.
Mal gucken, ob das hier irgendwie rumspackt.
Nö.
Macht's nicht.
Das habe ich zum ersten Mal kapiert, warum man mit der Maus so komisch rumwackeln muss.
Ich weiß, dass man das machen muss, aber ich hatte nie eine Ahnung, warum.
Also, wo das herkommt.
Genau.
Und dann dabei noch die Laufrichtung ändern.
Hin und her.
Also quasi strafen.
Strafen links und rechts und passen dazu dann quasi die Maus bewegen.
Jetzt habe ich das erst gecheckt, warum überhaupt die Leute zum Bunnyhoppen...
Also ich habe das ja in CS damals selbst geübt.
Warum das überhaupt...
Warum man das machen muss.
... von der Quake-Engine.
Selbst wenn die Technik bis jetzt noch nicht auf Maturität erreicht ist,
werden die Spieler definitiv beginnen zu verstehen, was gemacht werden muss, um die Frequenz zu maximieren.
Und in der 26. Juni 1998 würde Peter Horvath mehr Bunnyhoppen inkorporieren
und einen Zeitraum von 25 Sekunden erreichen.
Peter würde einen sogenannten Slope-Boost im Anfang des Levels implementieren.
Du kannst eine ziemlich signifikante Menge an Frequenz erzielen,
wenn du auf einer unteren Fläche bunnyhoppst.
Das Inverse ist auch wahr.
Wenn du von einer unteren Fläche bunnyhoppst, verlierst du eine Menge Frequenz.
Diese Mechanik ist tatsächlich ziemlich effektiv,
denn wenn man runterhüpft, ist man schneller,
wenn man hochspringt, ist man langsamer.
Und das Figurieren, wo man kann und wo man nicht springen kann,
ist ein großer Teil der Strategie.
Peters Rekord würde für fünf Monate stehen.
Am 11. November 1998 würde Ilka Kurkula das tun.
Der Bewegungsdruck in diesem Rennen ist ein Niveau,
was wir vorher gesehen hatten.
Und zum ersten Mal sahen wir die Implementierung einer Technik,
die Air-Strafing genannt wird.
Wir wissen bereits, dass Turnen während des Strafens
eine Erhöhung in der Geschwindigkeit erzeugen können.
Und wir wissen, dass so lange wir in der Luft sind,
es keine Mühe gibt, uns zu beschleunigen.
Aber das Einzige, was uns nicht klar ist,
ist der Fakt, dass wir Turnen und Strafing nutzen können,
um die Geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen,
auch während wir mitten im Luftraum sind.
Wenn es möglich ist, die Geschwindigkeit zu erhöhen,
während wir im Luftraum sind,
sollte dies das Zuschlag sein für die Wechseldrehbarkeit.
Wir sehen in der Geschwindigkeit,
wenn wir mit dem Gleitgerät breit Kontakt machen,
dass es kein Sound-Wind auslöst –
sondern das macht den Sound,
wie wir uns zu erkennen und anzusehen.
Und hier unten sieht man die Bahn,
und hier oben den Namen.
Dadurch erhält man ständig Geschwindigkeit
durch mehrere Starts.
In Ilkas 24-Klopper-Rennen
die ist erst rating around corners ist es der meiste intuitive place to execute
this manoeuvre as we are turning anyway what isn't intuitive is being able to
build speed with a strafing while traveling in straight lines by using
very precise timing we can gain speed by alternating a strafe between left and
right one thing that can't be overstated is just how much skill is needed to
perform and speak big brain movement
das ist ein stück mit dem maximum amount of speed takes extreme precision
i have to be honest and say that before making this video i had never learned
quake speed running techniques when i watched speed runs of quake the jumping
mechanic ist das der max ja das hat sie really can't appreciate just how
difficult good bunnyhopping is
ist das der max ja das hat sie wirklich can't appreciate just how difficult good bunnyhopping is
until you try it ja interessant ich dachte nicht dass es so
until you try it ja interessant ich dachte nicht dass es so nicht dass das so schwierig ist
nicht dass das so schwierig ist
nicht dass das so schwierig ist in a straight line without any obstacles was
in a straight line without any obstacles was
in a straight line without any obstacles was already incredibly frustrating once i
already incredibly frustrating once i
already incredibly frustrating once i had become comfortable with that i thought
had become comfortable with that i thought
had become comfortable with that i thought it would be pretty simple to apply it
it would be pretty simple to apply it
it would be pretty simple to apply it to e1 m1 and start speed running i was in
to e1 m1 and start speed running i was in
to e1 m1 and start speed running i was in for a very rude awakening though when
for a very rude awakening though when
Als ich angefangen habe, war es nicht möglich, in diesen kleinen Korridoren etwas zu tun.
Und ein kleiner Kontakt zu einer Wand oder einem Enemie verursacht einen riesigen Verlust der Geschwindigkeit.
Ich habe noch nicht gesagt, dass die Enemien die Fähigkeiten haben, deine Runden zu zerstören.
Die Enemie-Pathen sind random und einige von ihnen bewegen sich sehr schnell.
Sie sind groß und blockiert.
Wenn sie in deinem Weg kommen, bist du verletzt.
Sie haben auch ein hohes Level von Akkuratität.
Es war nicht so wichtig, wie gut mein Bewegung war.
Schießen war viel zu oft unerwartet.
Die Schaden von Enemien haben einen unglaublichen Rückgang.
Schießen von vorne zerstört deinen Rund.
Ilkas 24-Sekunden-Rund bleibt für sieben Monate im Rekord.
Während dieses Zeitraums sind die Fähigkeiten stetig verbessert.
Am 14. Juni 1999 würde Marcus Taipale einen neuen Benchmark mit diesem Rund setzen.
Ich finde das übelst interessant.
Ich hatte gar nicht gedacht, dass da so viel dazu gehört.
Also ich meine, mir war schon klar dass es nicht easy ist.
Aber das ist wirklich nicht ohne.
23 Sekunden!
Am Top-Levels braucht Quake Speedrunning viel Aufschritt.
Weil die Level-Designen so komplex sind,
ist coconmaue verschiedeneитemalt Martinjiarrenz
astronomisch größer.
Ziel ist es,
Oder Big Brain Strats.
Ach guck mal, der boostet sich jetzt mit der Tonne, du hast gesehen, der boostet sich jetzt
mit der Tonne.
Vorher haben sie die Tonne immer stehen lassen.
Easy kann ich auch.
Jaja, du kannst es auch im Multiplayer benutzen, aber da sind halt noch mehr Faktoren.
Checkt.
So.
Guckt euch mal an, mit wie viel Speed er jetzt durch den Korridor rennt, im Vergleich zu normal.
Nice!
Was?
Es ist halt ein Riesenunterschied zwischen den ersten paar Runs, die wir gesehen haben, und dem jetzt schon, ne?
Und wir sind erst 2001, also in den nächsten 10 Minuten geht wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen mehr ab.
Wo ist jetzt der Unterschied?
Ah, der ist näher, der ist...
Der ist näher an der Plattform gelaufen.
Also wirklich durchblicken, was jetzt anders ist, tue ich aber nicht mehr.
21!
Ui!
Okay, 17 Jahre ist krass.
Also 17 Jahre ist heftig.
17 Jahre Rekord.
17 Jahre ist echt heftig.
Okay, 21.63 in 2009.
In 2007, the Navigator would be the first to reach the record.
In 2009, the Navigator would be the first to reach the record.
In maid 19, and i. The last time, when I had 21.70 years, the 30-year old, i.
In 2009, the Navigator was 2 years old.
InADAM was die 19er, da warst du 2 Jahre, hey!
Inadam warst du 2 Jahre, hey!
In Instagram, der hatung geteoccted, in den novamente bleeding States.
In Instagram, der hatung geteoccted, in den weiterhin toasteder cryentide
Every time travel across the Aerial, in the
Marceling distributiert der und continues traveling across the necessar n Bless United,
Wisst ihr, was das richtig krasse an der Sache ist?
Dass die immer noch, immer noch neue Sachen in so einem alten Game,
vor allem, nee, nee, nee, nicht in so einem alten Game,
in so einem Mini-Abschnitt aus so einem alten Game finden.
Mit normalem Bunnyhopping gibt es eine Verlust von Geschwindigkeit,
je nachdem, wann der Spieler den Boden anreizt.
Dieser Geschwindigkeitsverlust erzeugt einen leichten Abstand von nur über 500 Units pro Sekunde.
Mit dieser Geschwindigkeit ist der Erstreifen nicht mehr als die Verlust von Friktion.
Mit dem Power-Bunnyhopping kann man viel von dieser Geschwindigkeitsverlust von Friktion negieren,
wenn man den Vorwärtsknopf drückt, wenn QuakeEye den Boden anreizt.
Das ist mir zu hoch jetzt, Leute, ich blick nicht mehr durch.
Er hat 580, jetzt geht's ab.
Illuminator, eigentlich gucke ich mir beides gerne an.
Wie bescheuert sieht das denn aus, sagt der ohne Kohl.
Das sieht bescheuert aus, aber es ist schnell.
Nein.
Okay.
Ah, habt ihr es gesehen?
Man kann jetzt damit sogar über, habt ihr es gesehen?
Man kann jetzt damit sogar über dieses Ding springen.
Ja, über dieses Ding springen, ohne dass man den Knopf und die, und die Leiter, ähm, triggern muss.
Das ist voll die Wissenschaft, das Ding.
Und nachdem er den 21 ohne den Boost erhielt, wusste er, dass er es niedriger drücken kann.
17,5 Jahre nachdem der originelle 21 auf dem 19. August 2018 gesetzt wurde,
hat Jukebox diesen Rund erreicht.
20 Sekunden.
Naja.
Easy.
Mach ich auch.
Bloß nicht on stream.
There is a lot to this run that I could cover.
If I were to explain every single detail going on in this record, this video would be two hours long.
There are very subtle maneuvers being executed at every step.
At the very beginning of the level, the slope boost is particularly precise.
If you land where the flat ground and the slope meet, you can reach the benefits of the steep...
Genau, 20 Jahre für 10 Sekunden gebraucht, was für Lappen.
Hahaha.
Nice.
...increase, while also retaining the ability to do a jump at full height.
Normally, when bunny hopping from a slope, some of the...
Aber ist schon krass, was da für Technik drin steckt, oder?
...transferred into horizontal speed, so some height is sacrificed.
If this beginning jump is not executed perfectly,
this will cause you to have to perform an extra jump in the sequence,
meaning that more speed is lost due to friction.
This maneuver only saves around two tenths of a second,
but in runs this optimized, it's a big deal.
The low ceiling makes this jump really difficult to do.
Near the end of the stage, he lands as close to the final ramp as possible.
This is so that the next jump will hit the ramp at a much shallower angle,
minimizing the speed loss.
This is because the angle at which you hit...
...the ramp will affect how great of an impact an upward or downward slope will have on your speed.
You'll notice that after the box boost, players will go out fairly wide as they navigate the next few corners.
This is due to the layout of the floor, and the fact that it is separated into different levels.
Quakeguy cannot clear more than two of these stairs with a single jump,
and given that it's impossible to bunny hop off stairs and maintain speed,
we can only use specific areas to land and still continue the bunny hop pattern.
This box's run of 20 seconds is really good, but it's still not perfect.
He knew almost immediately there were still areas that screamed for improvement.
In an ideal run, bunny hopping will remain continuous for the entire stage.
Bunny hopping is how we can take full advantage of the speed we have created through various techniques.
As soon as you stop jumping, you will...
...you will...
...you will lose all of the extra speed you have accumulated.
You'll lose all of the extra speed you have accumulated.
In the 20 second run, there were 3 places where the bunny hopping sequence was disrupted.
The first, was in the elevator at the start of the level.
It's pretty safe to say that stopping here is unavoidable,
as we need to wait for the lift to lower enough to exit.
The second instance was before the box boost.
This is to help set up the boost correctly to take full advantage of it.
Given that you need to be a specific distance away from the lift,
Okay, ich glaube ich habe es halbwegs gecheckt,
aber langsam wird es mir zu big brain, was die Leute machen müssen.
Heißt das also, diese Mechaniken waren von den Entwicklern so gewollt?
Also ich würde nicht sagen, dass die Entwickler das eingebaut haben,
dass man das so machen kann.
Ich würde eher sagen, das ist Nebeneffekte von dem, wie das Spiel programmiert ist.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass sie selber quasi auch schon gemerkt haben,
dass sowas möglich ist im Game und bewusst gesagt haben,
wir lassen das so.
Kennst du Summoning Saul, der macht History of Speed?
Ja, ja. Wir wollten uns noch Mario Kart von dem angucken, klar.
Wollen jeder, Mann.
Okay, das heißt im Endeffekt, er muss wirklich Millimeter genau durch das ganze Level springen.
Okay, das ist jetzt so schnell, dass ich überhaupt nicht mehr durchblicke.
Alter, krass, das ist der Unterschied zum ersten Run.
Nice.
Heftig, äh.
Heftig.
Der hat da tausende Stunden verübt, ja.
Das ist nicht einfach, ja. Das habe ich mittlerweile auch gecheckt.
Das ist so.
Easy.
Echt heftig, echt heftig, ey, ich, also mir war schon, das ist Quake, mir war schon immer
klar, was man machen muss, so ungefähr, zum Bunnyhoppen in Quake-basierten Games, aber was da alles
dahinter steckt, ist der Wahnsinn, das hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, jetzt weiß ich auch, warum man, warum man
hin und her wackelt, mit der Maus, geil, echt nicht schlecht, also das Video hat mir gefallen, ich meine,
hätte vielleicht ein bisschen interessanter sprechen können, ja, ich muss sagen, das Commentary war jetzt
ein bisschen monoton, hat doch, glaube ich, schon jemand im Chat gerade geschrieben, aber das
war wirklich ziemlich gut erklärt, so Leute, ähm, jetzt ist die Frage, ich bin jetzt 2 Stunden an,
wollen wir uns noch die History of Rainbow Road World Records angucken, das geht allerdings 47 Minuten,
wir könnten uns auch noch nur ein kurzes 18 Minuten Video angucken, wobei ich das Video schon mal gesehen
habe, das ist auch ziemlich gut, rein da, Pogu, okay, 18 Minuten, ah, okay,
dann gucken wir 18 Minuten, okay, gut, das ist aber von 2015, da müssen wir mal gucken, wie viel davon noch aktuell ist,
aber wahrscheinlich, ähm, wird das immer noch zutreffen, vielleicht gucken wir auch einfach beides,
vielleicht gucken wir auch einfach beides, Pogu aus Musik, Black Ops 3, wenn ihr euch tollt, Black Ops 3,
On April 26, Activision revealed Call of Duty Black Ops 3 to the world, a world that has spawned 20,
three games in this one franchise, Call of Duty has earned its reputation in the video game world as being the mediums equivalent of Michael Bay's Transformers,
it's the franchise everyone swears is the most wretched piece of aging Phil since Pat Robinson,
yet every time November rolls around, it sends sales charts rocketing towards Neptune, even when it's dying and losing momentum,
it's still got the world's do-go population,
cracking open a 12-pack of wands in glee, Call of Duty is a franchise that's known for its progression-based multiplayer and ubiquitous advertising,
so it's easy to forget, also Dorito Chips kann ich noch verstehen, Mountain Dew ist übelst abartig, genauso wie Dr. Pepper ist auch übelst abartig,
Dorito Chips verstehe ich, diese Tortilla Chips an sich kannst du eigentlich tütenweise fressen, aber Dr. Pepper und Mountain Dew, das verstehe ich nicht, wie man das trinkt,
es ist unheimlich bauartig und mit anstrengenden Hinsichten, aber um das zu bestätigen, müssen wir zurückkommen zu 12 Jahren, als ich mein erstes Nazi-Bild erschossen hatte.
,
Call of Duty 2 wurde 2005 für die PC im Oktober überlegt, und ein Monat später auf Microsofts nächster Generation Console, dem Xbox 360.
Call of Duty 2 war wirklich der dritte im ganzen Series, weil Metal-of-Honor Allied Assault Grundsatz für den Erfolg von Call of Duty wurde,
und wurde entdeckt von vielen der gleichen Teamleute.
,
Das war mein erstes Kopf!
Der Master Chief, was hat der damit zu tun?
Im Jahr 2005 begannen einige Schützer, Dinge zu vermischen.
SWAT 4 gab dir die Aufgabe...
Oh, was für eine Bildqualität!
Huge Quali!
Oh, Vier! Vier war auch ein nices Game. Haben wir sogar mal im Stream durchgespielt.
Call of Duty 2 war nicht ein Power Trip von einem FPS.
Es ging darum, nur noch ein Soldat auf dem Spielfeld zu sein,
und in meiner Meinung nach erreicht es das besser als andere Spiele seit der Eröffnung.
Call of Duty 2 geht nicht um Set-Pieces oder pseudo Quick-Time Events.
Es geht darum zu überleben,
den größten menschlichen Konflikt in der ganzen Geschichte.
Um die Ordnung der Kampagnen des letzten Spiels zu verändern,
beginnt man als Privat in der russischen Armee,
während der Beobachtung von Stalingrad.
Nach einer kurzen Tutorial-Sequenz wird dein kontrollierter Sektor von deutschen Kräften getötet,
und du musst ihnen helfen, mit deinen Freunden wegzukommen.
Und das ist, wie jeder Level weitergeht.
Waffen, Feuer und Schreien, bis alle fehlenden Kräfte ausgelöscht werden.
Obwohl es ein lineares Spiel ist,
macht das Skript und Audio-Design dir eine unglaubliche Arbeit,
diese Welt zu verkaufen.
Und das Spiel-Spiel ist,
um das zu reflektieren.
Anders als in späteren Spielen in der Franchise,
ist Call of Duty 2 ein Spiel,
in dem die Schwierigkeiten der Veteranen
die wichtigste Weise sind, das Spiel zu spielen.
Die wenigen Hits, die du nimmst,
sind wirklich eine Art Platzstab,
in dem es oft nicht eine Option ist,
wenn du mit dem Gunnen spielst.
Es geht darum,
dass du auf deine Bewegungen vorsichtig bist,
und dass du in deinem Schießen konsistent bist.
Weil wenn Dinge falsch gehen,
und die Feinde mit vollautomatischen Sub-Maschinen-Gunnen
dir nahe kommen,
ist deine einzige Möglichkeit,
dich zu paniken und jede Runde abzuschalten.
Dies ist auch wegen der Unmöglichkeit,
Sprint-Button zu nutzen.
Das Regenerieren der Gesundheit
ist etwas,
das viele Menschen über-
Stimmt!
Man konnte in Call of Duty 2 gar nicht sprinten, ne?
Ich erinnere mich wieder,
da musste man eine Pistole nehmen,
dass man schneller läuft.
... aber es war eine gesetzliche Wahl
von Infinity Ward,
als es in diesem Spiel debutierte.
Fast jeder Level ist ein riesiges Spielfeld,
wo Explosionen und Schussfeuer ein Konzept sind.
Richtig selten gibt es jemals einen Abstand.
Und wir lernen,
diese wenigen kurzen Momente des Stimmens zu genießen.
Die Anzahl der Gesundheits-Packs,
die in jedem Level benötigt werden,
wäre sehr hoch.
Das könnte sich beschädigen
und den Spiel spätstattichen.
occupier den400-Klimax,
das ist einer der mühistesten Missionen des Spiels.
Ein unabhängiger Adrenalin-Rusch,
bis die bewegten Militär rewards kommen.
Die einzige Möglichkeit für Gesundheits-Packs im Regener-
...
Das war wirklich cool ...
Das was Core 2 halt wirklich ...
aus der damaligen Zeit rausgehoben hat,
war das es halt nicht so viele Sachen
in dieser Richtung gegeben hat.
Wenn man das heute spielt,
nachdem man 95 andere Codes gespielt hat,
ist das jetzt nicht mehr so der Wahnsinn.
Aber für die damalige Zeit war man voll am Ende, wenn man da so ein Level durchgespielt hat.
Es wäre gut, wenn eine der Räume in deinem Bunker eine Schale von ihnen hätte und sie nur das Pacing töten würde.
Oder sie in spezifischen Bereichen auf dem Map ausbreiten, um den Spieler die Wahl, woher er gehen soll, zu verhindern.
Wie in der Halo-Serie ist Call of Duty 2 eines der wenigen Spiele, die dieses regenerierende Gesundheitssystem korrekt verwendet.
Du fühlst dich wirklich glücklich, je nachdem wie oft du einen Schusskampf überlebst,
nur um zu sehen, wie gut deine Teamleute waren, die nicht so glücklich waren.
Ja, das Tank-Level war dumm.
Sei mal nur! Zwei Monate, danke.
Ich bin ein Fuchs.
Ich bin ein Fuchs, ich bin ein Fuchs, ich bin ein Fuchs!
Now it's a ghost town.
Nee, wie ging das?
50.000 people used to live here, now it's a ghost town.
Waren das 50.000? 20.000? Wie viel waren's?
Ich glaub 50.000 waren's, ne?
Das ist der originale Captain Price.
Call of Duty 4 didn't dominate the gaming media airwaves like many people think.
It's easy to forget due to Call of Duty 4's success, but Halo 3 was a game taking charge of the hype train.
It stormed the stores to get their hands on Halo 3.
The game was September's top seller, with 3.3 million copies flying off the shelves,
more than twice as many as the nine runners-up combined.
I remember back in 2007 being surprised as a fan of both franchises at just how quickly the tables turned.
Halo had been such a dominant force in the industry, to the point where even Call of Duty was taking notes from it.
And to see Call of Duty overtake Halo in sales was a surprise to say the least.
Obviously, Activision had a bit of an advantage, being that...
Jetzt weil er gerade Halo erwähnt hat, ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass von Halo-Teil zu Halo-Teil Cortana größere Dinger hatte?
Außer im letzten, da ist es wieder ein bisschen weniger geworden.
Their game was available on three different platforms, but it's still an impressive feat nevertheless.
While it is true that many lazy trends were adopted from Call of Duty 4,
it's an exceptional game that, just like Call of Duty 2, uses all of its mechanics effectively.
And that need for purpose has also translated to storytelling.
Being a World War 2 series, Call of Duty was always pretty light when it came to narrative.
Call of Duty 3 probably had the most, which isn't saying a whole lot.
Disclaimer, heavy spoilers for Call of Duty 4 Modern Warfare will be discussed.
Was hatte Call of Duty 3 am meisten? Ich hab's grad nicht gecheckt.
Spoilers bei nem zehn Jahre alten Game, zwölf Jahre alten Game.
Similar to Infinity Ward's last effort, Call of Duty 4 is not a power fantasy.
In fact, it's a game based on a fantasy. In other words, it's a game based on a fantasy.
In other words, it's a game based on a fantasy. In other words, it's a game based on a fantasy.
In fact, the game structures its campaign to take power away from the player.
Ja. Das stimmt. Das stimmt.
As in Call of Duty 2, we're given a brief tutorial before being dropped into the action.
This time, beginning on a tanker with valuable intel.
Du hast in Call of Duty eigentlich das Gefühl gehabt, du kriegst auf dem Sammel.
While it's true that you're now part of the British Special Forces,
the game reminds you that your character is a newbie.
The rookie who needs to earn respect from his superiors.
Die Seife!
As a result, the game still keeps its design principle of not making you out to be this larger-than-life hero.
Seife, beste!
Another thing Act 1 does by having you play as a new member of the SAS
is being able to start the game with less explosive and quieter sections,
where new players have an easier time getting used to the game's gameplay.
Ich hab das nie auf Deutsch gespielt, aber die haben Saub nicht übersetzt, oder?
Der Typ heißt doch bestimmt auch Saub in Deutsch.
...in pacing.
These prepare you for the American missions that match the intensity of Call of Duty 2.
At the start, America seems to be doing all the heavy lifting,
looking for the game's red herring, Al-Assad.
As the Americans, you contribute to these heroic and daring pushes against enemy forces,
when the stakes get raised and the threat of a nuclear weapon is proposed.
But being the heroic American soldier that you are going in to save the world,
you attempt to rescue a pilot injured in a helicopter crash.
But unlike most games, you don't get rewarded for being the hero.
Das hat mich so geschockt damals, oder?
Leute!
Das hat mich so geschockt damals, oder? Leute!
Das war die Szene und die, die danach kommt, ist das, wo sie es tatsächlich geschafft haben,
einmal in der Call of Duty-Kampagne und vor allem, weil es halt auch das erste Mal war,
so richtig zu überraschen.
Niemand hatte gedacht, dass erstens die Nuke hochgeht in dem Game
und zweitens, dass der Held quasi aufs Maul kriegt.
Der neue MW-Teil soll noch krasser werden.
Jaja, die erzählen viel, weil der Tag lang ist. Wird er nicht.
Der neue MW-Teil soll noch krasser werden. Wird er nicht.
Wird er nicht.
Die Schuhe werden plötzlich auf den anderen Fuß genommen.
Die S.A.S.
ist so ein effektives Stück sozialer Kommentar und Satire, weil es so aufstehend ist.
Der Atem user- und Lack von Musik und die Unwahrheit, die Welt außerhalb von warmem Wissen zu sehen,
erschüttert den undownernden Zusammenhang zwischen dir selber und den Menschen, die du tötest.
der undownernden Zusammenhang zwischen dir selber und die Leute, die du tötest.
ja die Unwahrheit, die Lack von Musik und die Unwahrheit, die Luft nicht überbringen.
Dies ist ein Trilog, der in diesen Tagen mit Action-Games so üblich geworden ist,
aber fast alle, außer Spek-Offs, merken nicht, wie subtil dieses Trilog in Call of Duty 4 ist.
Dieses Level wird nur mit der Äußerung,
besonders nach dem realistischen Foto von Schiffsschiff-Attacken,
der im Internet geleakt wird, ziemlich unangenehm.
Während Call of Duty 4 sich von der Franchise aus entfernt,
macht es das mit Grund und zieht es in eine effektive und nachdenkliche Art aus,
die immer noch mit Gamern zusammenhängt.
Und es hilft auch, dass sie es mit dem Multiplayer getötet haben.
Infinity War ist ein Spiel, das als emotionales Zeitalter moderner Kriege funktioniert
und als ein großer, dummer Schütze, um Terroristen zu töten.
Alle Widerstände passen zusammen in den richtigen Orten,
mit dem einzigen Fehlpunkt des Spiels, das mit einem vollendeten Ende endet.
Call of Duty 4 ist ein tolles Spiel und obwohl es nicht mein persönlicher Lieblingsspiel ist,
sehe ich, dass es absolut der hohe Punkt der Serie ist.
Call of Duty World at War ist das letzte Spiel, das mit den originalen Designprinzipien von Call of Duty verbunden ist.
Es gibt sogar ein paar Dinge, die es besser macht als Call of Duty 2.
Das Hauptes ist die Vorstellung von Gewalt in der Zweiten Weltkriege.
World at War ist wahrscheinlich das größtmütigste Spiel der Serie.
Es beginnt nicht mal mit einer Tutorial-Sequenz.
Die Eröffnungsszene des Spiels betrachtet einen Soldaten,
der seinen Mund von einem japanischen Interrogator geschnitten hat.
Es war das erste Mal, dass Call of Duty das Pacifische Theater der Weltkriege besucht hat
und die Entwickler bei Treyarch ein exzellentes Spiel gemacht haben,
um zu bestätigen, wie anders die japanischen Kämpfe sind als die der Deutschen.
Das Spiel leuchtet nicht, wenn man in Russland kommt,
denn die Eröffnungsszene für diese Sektion ist,
wo du und Gary Oldmans Charakter Reznov mit toten Kameraden zusammenarbeiten musstest,
die von den Nazi-Fürsachen massakriert werden.
Aber was so einzigartig ist, ist, dass die Brutalität hier nicht nur mit den Achsen dargestellt wird,
sondern auch mit den Alliieren.
Später im Spiel, wenn die Russen Raum über Raum gehen,
die jeden Deutschen in ihrem Weg schlagen,
gibt es einen Moment, in dem drei Jungen, die sich um die Tür befinden,
und drei Nazi-Fürsachen, die sich um die Tür befinden,
zurückkehren,
nur um entweder von dem Spieler abgerissen zu werden
oder von deinen Teammätern verbrannt zu werden.
Während es mehr auf Sektionen als Call of Duty 2 fokussiert ist
und nicht ganz so aufregend ist,
ist es immer noch eine sehr gut konstruierte Kampagne,
die nur ein World War 2 Mod für Modern Warfare aufwächst.
Es ist ein schmutziges Spiel mit vielen Höhen und Löhnen,
die direkt am Emotionshochststand schlagen.
Während es das letzte Mal wäre, dass Call of Duty World War 2 besucht,
war es effektiv
und hat einen satisfeindlichen Anruf.
Aber dann ist etwas passiert.
MW2?
Spiele sind kompliziert.
Und AAA-Spiele sind sogar noch komplizierter,
wenn nicht wegen der Anzahl der Leute, die auf einem einzigen Projekt arbeiten,
sowohl auf der Entwicklungsseite als auch auf der Publizierungsebene.
Ich weiß nicht, welche Entscheidung es war,
das, was bis jetzt schon war,
eine Vorstellung von Krieg,
in eine Ball-zu-der-Walle-Aktion zu verwenden.
MW2 und Black Ops 1
waren die letzten Call of Duties,
wo mich die Kampagne so richtig abgeholt hat.
Modern Warfare 2 ist ein Spiel,
in dem die Singleplayer-Kampagne
in den Overdrive gekippt wurde,
der Scharke springte
und in das Kapital-Territorium von Batshit landete.
Das ist, wo Call of Duties heruntergekommen ist.
Auf der Oberfläche ist es vielleicht nur Call of Duty 4.5,
aber die Unterschiede zwischen Modern Warfare 2 und früheren Spielen
sind nicht ihre Mechaniken,
sondern eher die Art, wie sie verwendet werden
und der Kontext, in den die Mechaniken verwendet werden.
Call of Duty hat immer neue Szenen,
aber es ist Modern Warfare 2,
der besagt hat, dass es die Äquivalente
der Nuke-Szene braucht,
jede 45 Minuten.
Wenn man die Tutorial-Sequenz des Spiels beendet,
wird man in der Turret-Szene von On Rails
innerhalb von Minuten
auf den ersten Niveau des Spiels gebootet.
Und es ist nicht nur...
Die hatte...
Ich muss hier gerade...
Die hatten in MW2 halt einen übelst geilen Soundtrack.
Ah.
Kannst du noch einen dran erinnern?
Das war ein nicer Soundtrack.
Also echt, das war...
Der Soundtrack war...
MW2 hat den besten Soundtrack gehabt.
Die geilen Sprecher AC-130...
Ja, der russische AC-130-Sprecher war der beste.
Enemy AC-130 above!
Den merkt man sich bis heute.
Wille Games regulieren.
Ja, die flippen wir jetzt alle aus.
Ramirez!
Genau, MW2.
Ramirez.
Ramirez muss alles machen.
Der Stelzklauen war auch noch am Start.
...
MW2 versucht, den Spieler als Badass zu fühlen,
indem er seine oder ihre Aktionen restriktiert.
Anstatt mit deinen Brüdern in Normandie an die Flügel zu stürzen,
enternstürzt er sich selbst in die Hölle.
Du bist derjenige, der die gesamte Miliz in Brasilien einschlägt.
Das wäre natürlich kein Problem,
wenn das Spiel mit dieser Ein-Mann-Armee-Super-Soldat-Struktur
vorgestellt würde.
Aber das ist es nicht.
Es trägt immer noch Mechaniken und Spielzeug
aus einem 2-Jahre-Vertrag, der vor vier Jahren veröffentlicht wurde.
Oh.
Lass mich es so sagen.
Stell dir vor, dass du die selben Mechaniken und Spielzeug aus Halo
benutzt hast, aber mit dem Level-Design und den Fehlplätzen von Rainbow Six.
Alles, was MW2 so spezifisch gemacht hat, wird in einen Michael-Bay-Rollercoaster
auf Steroiden eingeschüttelt.
Mit Glöcknern, Schiffschüsse und explodierenden Spacestationen.
Und das funktioniert nicht.
All das könnte verabschiedet werden, wenn, wie in Call of Duty 4,
diese Entscheidungen an die Geschichte eingeführt werden.
Aber du bekommst nur eine Auswahl von Ebenen, die sich mehr fühlen, als ob die Schriftsteller
versuchen würde, sich zu verabschieden, mit wem sie das schrecklichste Set-Piece
finden könnten.
Spoilers für Modern Warfare 2 werden diskutiert.
Nicht, dass du es interessierst.
Die Sequenz des Flughafens, die alle erschreckt hat, als es online geleakt wurde,
schriekt von der Verschwörung der Entwickler, etwas mehr zu machen.
Das war das erste Mal, was sie eingebaut haben, nur, dass die Presse sich drüber aufregen kann.
Das hat storymäßig überhaupt nichts dazu beigetragen.
Das Wichtige am Ende war eigentlich nur, dass das Makarov dann den Agent erschießt.
Das hätte man komplett anders lösen können, als mit dieser Mission.
Zumal diese Mission auch überhaupt nicht in die restliche Struktur irgendwie reinpasst.
Außerdem, ich meine, mir geht es nicht darum, ob Call of Duty irgendwie realistisch ist
oder sonst was, aber das ist auch schon für Call of Duty Missionen echt krass an den Haaren
herbeigezogen.
Die kommen da mit gezücktem LMG in der Hüfte an und stehen da im Flughafen rum.
Also, das ist sogar für Call of Duty-Verhältnisse irgendwie weit an den Haaren herbeigezogen.
Es hat nichts zu sagen außerhalb der Narrative.
Und innerhalb der Narrative ist es nur ein Plot-Device, um Russland in Amerika zu überwachen.
Ein Plot-Device, das verfehlt wird, weil es mehr Löcher hat als jeder der Zivilisten, die du erschossen hast.
Vorher wurden Kampagnen so gestaltet, dass sie von sowohl casualen als auch enthusiastischen Spielern genutzt werden können.
Wenn du in die Welt des Spiels weiterentwickeln und dich immerzen willst, kannst du das machen.
Aber wenn du dein Gehirn wegwerfen und Dinge schießen willst, kannst du das auch machen.
In Modern Warfare 2 wird dein Gehirn weggeworfen, um Dinge zu schießen.
In Modern Warfare 2 wird dein Gehirn weggeworfen und Dinge zu schießen.
Das stimmt fast, da hat es schon was dran.
Jetzt hat die Serie das auch verloren.
Diese Franchise ist in das gleiche Spiel geformt, das ihr inneres Design ausgebaut hat, um zu vermeiden.
Beispiel.
In Call of Duty 2 hat die Finale der russischen Kampagne einen wichtigen Sektor der Stadt gegen einen deutschen Konterattacken.
Mit einem Snipergerät beginnt man, die Feinde der Gegner zu bewegen.
Mit dem Snipergerät wird eine ganze Strecke überwacht, in der man solche Feinden nicht mehr verhindern kann.
Man wird aber nicht so betroffen, dass du noch nicht kennengelernt werden kannst.
Man wird nicht so betroffen, dass du noch nicht kennengelernt wirst.
Man wird quasi überwacht, dass du dich entsetzt wirst zwischen verschiedenen Räumen zu werfen.
Man muss so viele Naxen wie möglich mit einem Snipergerät töten, um sich bei einem dichter Renntagrohr zu verletzen.
Mannschaft wird nicht so leidenswert, wie bei einem Kampage, der sich aber auf einem Gerüst konzentriert.
Es ist ein einfaches, aber gut designtes Stadion, das sich durch sinnvolles Gameplay umsetzen kann, eine tense und erfreuliche Erfahrung.
Verwenden Sie dieses Stadion zu Call of Duty Ghosts.
Nicht so weit in der Serie, gibt es ein Level, wo Sie sich gegen die Föderation befinden.
Sie machen das, indem Sie sich auf einen Turret befinden und den Trigger halten, bis das Spiel sich von Ihnen nicht mehr erinnern kann.
Dann sitzen Sie da, bis das Spiel Ihnen sagt, ein iPad aus dem Arsch zu holen und überpowerte Maschinen und ein Flugzeug zu benutzen, das über Ihre Feinde fliegt.
Sie machen das, bis das Spiel Sie aus dem Turret forciert, das Spiel Sie darauf forciert.
Ein Grupp von Spielen benötigt ihre lineare Struktur, um eine meticulöse und kompensierende Erfahrung zu schaffen, die von Anfang bis Schluss eine tiefgewovene Reise war.
Ein anderer benötigt seine lineare Struktur, um den Spieler zu beobachten und zu verabschieden von Anfang bis Schluss.
Ich habe diese Serie bis Call of Duty Ghosts verteidigt.
Ich habe mit Leuten verabschiedet, dass die Serie in ein dummes Spiel wurde, aber zumindest hatten diese Spiele die Zufriedenheit, mit ihrer Blödsinn zu haben.
Jetzt können sie sich nicht mehr daran erinnern, dumm zu sein, und diese Serie hat sich seitdem in einem unendlichen Pittfall verletzt.
Call of Duty Ghosts hat seine Kampagne kopiert und gepastet und eine Kollektion von anderen Spielen von All-Rage-Systemen veröffentlicht.
Advanced Warfare hat Frogger in einem der Spiele-Set-Piecen veröffentlicht.
Diese Teams von talentierten und kreativen Individuen spenden Tausende von Stunden und Millionen von Dollar, um eine 60-Dollar-Edition von Simon Says zu machen.
Call of Duty hat nicht das gleiche Spiel veröffentlicht.
Diese Spiele haben sich seit über 10 Jahren veröffentlicht.
Was sie veröffentlicht hat, ist eine Schale ihres ehemaligen Selbsts, ein ehemaliges Selbst, das respektiert wurde.
x, x, es ist Xbox, äh, es ist Konsole.
Hat er nicht unrecht? Es ist ja auch nicht wirklich besser geworden, ne?
Und auch wenn sie jetzt natürlich erzählen, so nach dem Motto, sie wollen an COD 4 anknüpfen und irgendwie, es wird noch besser, noch größer und sonst was.
Ganz ehrlich, die müssen, die...
Vom Reden, vom Reden wird das nicht passieren.
Die müssen schon irgendwie so die Taten sprechen lassen, ja, die müssen das machen.
Es wird nicht wahrer dadurch, dass man es möglichst oft wiederholt.
Man muss es zeigen, dass es so ist.
Und ich kann viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist, ja, aber davon wird es nicht wahrer.
Und wann kommt denn das eigentlich raus?
Achso, ja, 2019.
Da hat es schon den Namen.
12. September, ne, ne, ne, ähm...
25. Oktober.
Also noch 20 Tage, 22 Tage.
22 Tage.
Er hat das beste Ausgang, und zwar Black Ops 1, ja, das Video war ja schon lang genug.
Um seinen Punkt rüber zu bringen, war das jetzt nicht notwendig.
Warum ist mein Google...
Achso, drei Zähne haben wir ja schon.
12 Tage.
12...
Quick Muffs.
Ähm, dauert ja nicht mehr lang, zwei Wochen noch.
Also, es heißt übernächste Woche Freitag, hä?
Da...
Gibt's irgendwie Early Access oder sowas, wenn man es vorbestellt hat?
Nee, gibt's nicht?
Ok.
Naja.
Ist eigentlich auch besser so.
So, Leute, jetzt haben wir ja ein paar Subs bekommen.
Euer Durchschnitts-IQ ist gestiegen, genauso wie meiner.
Hat jetzt einer eine Idee, wie ich das hier richtig anschließen könnte?
Am Anfang hatte ja auch keiner eine Idee.
Ich vermute mal, dass selbst der Sub-Count jetzt nichts dazu beigetragen wird.
Hat...
Master Cell hat abonniert, habe ich ganz übersehen.
Dankeschön, Twitch Prime.
Ich...
Samu...
Sa...
Scrymer!
Pry...
Samu...
Nice!
Also, Drähte dran lösen.
Ähm...
Also, was ich machen will...
Ähm, nur mal so kurz angemerkt.
Ich habe mir einen SATA auf...
Einen USB auf SATA Adapter gekauft.
Und ich würde das gerne an so einen Festplatten-Wechselrahmen anschließen.
Sieht dann so hinten aus.
Der hat aber bloß noch...
Normale SATA-Stecker.
Das heißt, ich muss irgendwie von da...
Auf da kommen.
Und ein normales SATA-Kabel passt da nicht ran.
Vielleicht hatte irgendwie einer eine chlorreiche Idee.
Bist du auch schon auf die neuen Konsolen gehypt?
Nö.
Ich...
Ich warte mal ab.
Ich warte mal ab, was da kommt.
Ähm...
Weil...
Die letzte Konsolengeneration hat mich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich enttäuscht.
Also...
Die letzte Konsolengeneration hat mich nicht überzeugt.
Und ich muss euch ehrlich sagen...
Mir kam diese Konsolengeneration auch übelst kurz vor.
Obwohl sie eigentlich von der Länge her auch nicht so viel länger...
Also so viel kürzer oder eher gleich lang war wie die letzte Konsolengeneration.
Ja, also...
Ich glaube sieben Jahre in dem Fest.
Sechs, sieben Jahre, ja.
Also es ist kein großer Unterschied.
Aber es kam mir kurz vor.
Und so viele Sachen, muss man auch mal sagen.
So viele Sachen gab es nicht.
Es gab sehr viele.
Also hätte es nicht die ganzen Re-Releases gegeben.
Und Remakes.
Und Remastered.
Und Neuauflagen.
Und HD-Editions und so.
Wäre es mit Spielen auf der aktuellen Konsolengeneration echt eng geworden, ne?
Ja, und dazu kam dieser Zwischenrelease, der es auch nicht gerade besser gemacht hat.
Aber das Problem war, dass die Konsolen, die aktuellen ja schon zum Release-Zeitpunkt ziemlich schwachbrüstig waren.
Und die mussten ja irgendwas machen, dass das Zeug ordentlich läuft.
Das wird diesmal nicht so sein.
Diesmal kriegen die aktuellen Konsolen wieder halbwegs...
Ein halbwegs ordentliches Hardware-Setup.
Wobei man sagen muss...
Dass auch die nicht einem PC, der bei Release aktuell ist, irgendwie das Wasser reichen können werden.
Ja.
Also, leistungsmäßig, wie wir das gesehen haben, bei der Xbox 360 und bei der PS3.
Ich glaube, so einen Leistungsboost, beziehungsweise Unterschied zur letzten Generation werden wir nicht mehr sehen.
Ale.
Kuluki 97.
Zwei Monate.
Danke schön.
Poggers.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass sie jetzt wenigstens eine ordentliche Kernanzahl haben in den neuen Konsolen.
Ja, das wird dann wahrscheinlich was für ein 8-Kerner oder so.
Und es wird auch ordentlich viel RAM geben.
Endlich mal eine SSD.
Das wird auch mal Zeit.
Aber ansonsten, im Vergleich zu einem...
Wenn ich mir jetzt einen aktuellen Ryzen-Desktop-PC kaufe, ist der immer noch besser als eine Konsole.
Gut, der kostet ja auch das Vierfache.
Das 3- bis Vierfache.
Ja.
Gibt einen USB-SATA-Konverter mit dem Anschluss.
Ja, aber nur USB-2 oder irgendeinen Müll mit schlechten Bewertungen.
Aber schick mal einen Link.
Vielleicht hast du ja noch was anderes gefunden.
Haben die SATA oder NVMe?
Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht bekannt.
Aber macht eigentlich keinen großartigen Unterschied.
Ich meine, natürlich ist NVMe deutlich schneller.
Aber es geht ja um Zugriffszeiten.
Bei den Games.
Und äh...
Ist dann nicht so...
Ein großer Unterschied.
Ich könnte mir tatsächlich vorstellen,
dass es NVMe ist.
Ähm...
Weil es einfach schön aufs Board drauf gesteckt werden kann.
Aber auf der anderen Seite kostet NVMe mehr.
Was auch wieder für SATA sprechen würde.
Ja, ich guck's mal an.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt mir mal Mittagessen bestellen.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich hab noch nichts gegessen.
Und war schön, dass ihr alle dabei wart.
Falls ihr nicht wisst, wohin mit eurem Twitch Prime-Sub,
würde ich mich drüber freuen.
Und mal gucken, ob das mit einem neuen Video heute was wird.
Ob ich das noch auf die Reihe kriege.
Weil ich wollte ja eigentlich das Fiverr-Video machen.
Aber ich hab's noch nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt,
dass es da mir eine ordentliche Struktur dafür zu überlegen.
Für das Fiverr-Sub.
Äh, Fiverr-Sub.
Fiverr-Video.
Alter, jetzt bin ich komplett verwirrt.
Gucken wir mal.
Also Leute, macht's gut.
Bis dann.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Video oder im nächsten Stream.
Ciao.